This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. Therapy is a great tool for facing your fears and finding ways to overcome them. Because sometimes the scariest thing is not facing our fears in the first place. That's right. And therapy is a great tool for facing your fears. And you know fear can be such a stumbling block in your life and we are all fearful. And what a better thing to do than to talk it out with someone. If you're thinking of starting therapy you could give
本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。心理疗法是面对恐惧和找到克服恐惧方法的绝佳工具。因为有时候最可怕的事情恰恰是我们一开始不敢去直面恐惧。没错。心理疗法确实是正视恐惧的好方法。你知道恐惧会成为你生活中的绊脚石，而我们每个人都会感到恐惧。还有什么比跟别人倾诉更好的办法呢？如果你正在考虑开始做心理咨询，你可以给
BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online. It is designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Here's how it works. You fill out a questionnaire. You will get matched with a licensed therapist, and you can switch therapists at any time for no additional charge. So if this feels like something that you might want to give a try, you can overcome your fears with BetterHelp. Visit BetterHelp.com slash office ladies today to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelp, H-E- e l p dot com slash office ladies.
BetterHelp 一个机会。它完全在线上进行。它的设计非常便捷、灵活，并且能够配合你的时间表。具体流程如下。你填写一份问卷。你将与一位持证心理咨询师进行匹配，而且你可以随时更换咨询师，无需支付任何额外费用。所以，如果你觉得这值得一试，你可以通过 BetterHelp 战胜恐惧。今天就访问 BetterHelp.com 斜杠 office ladies，首月即可享九折优惠。网址是 BetterHelp，也就是 H-E-E-L-P 点 com 斜杠 office ladies。
I'm Dave and saving with TD insurance made me feel like I scored my own jingle. Save on home and auto like only you can at td insurance.com slash ways to save TD. Ready for you. Hi everyone. We recorded today's episode a few weeks ago, but before we play it for you today, we wanted to pop on because Jenna,
我是戴夫，使用 TD 保险省下的钱让我感觉就像创作了自己的专属广告歌。来 tdinsurance.com/waystosaveTD，享受唯你专享的房屋和汽车保险优惠。TD，时刻为您准备。大家好。我们几周前录制了今天的节目，但在播放之前，我们想先插播一段，因为珍娜，
you shared something very personal on your Instagram and you said you'd also like to share it here on Office Ladies. Yes. And this is our second try at this because I got so emotional the first time we started talking about it. It's just really hard when someone you care about is going through so much. But I told Angela that if she starts crying, then I'll start crying.
你在 Instagram 上分享了一件非常私人的事情，而且你说你也想在《办公室女士》里分享它。是的。这是我们第二次尝试录制这段内容，因为第一次聊起这个话题时，我情绪实在太激动了。每当你在乎的人经历那么多苦难时，那种感觉真的很艰难。但我告诉安吉拉，如果她开始哭，那我也要开始哭了。
Yeah. I know, Jenna, you have so much you want to say. Yeah. So I'm aware that this is a big share, and it's kind of hard to know where to start. But since I'm one of those people who tends to deal with emotional subjects by leaning into facts and statistics, we all know that an Excel spreadsheet is my happy place. It really is. I will start there. Last December, I was diagnosed with stage one triple positive
是的。我知道，珍娜，你心里有太多话想说。是的。所以我也知道这是一次重大的分享，而且很难知道该从哪里说起。但既然我是那种习惯通过倾向于事实和数据来处理情感话题的人，大家都知道 Excel 表格是我的快乐老家。确实如此。那我就从那里开始说起吧。去年的十二月，我被诊断出患有一期三阳性
breast cancer and for anyone who doesn't know what that means I did not have a clue. Triple positive breast cancer is a very aggressive form of breast cancer that can spread and grow quite quickly but luckily my cancer was caught very early. It had not spread into my lymph nodes or anywhere else in my body. However, it still required the greatest hits of cancer treatments, surgery, chemotherapy, radiation. All of which has been going on this past year.
乳腺癌。对于任何不知道这是什么意思的人来说，我当时也毫无头绪。三阳性乳腺癌是一种侵袭性极强的乳腺癌，它可能会非常快速地扩散和生长，但幸运的是，我的癌症发现得很早。它没有扩散到我的淋巴结或身体的其他任何地方。不过，它仍然需要癌症治疗的“豪华套餐”——手术、化疗、放疗。所有这些治疗都持续了过去整整一年。
And lady, I know someday you're gonna share more about this in your time when you're ready, but I just have to tell everyone as your BFF, I can't believe how much you held onto these past few months. Well, I have to say, I've had a lot of people helping me hold onto this. I know. I did not carry this alone. I know you didn't, but you just had such courage and such grace. And you know, I'll cry if we talk about it too much, but I want you to share the first
亲爱的，我知道总有一天，等你准备好的时候，你会分享更多关于这方面的经历，但我作为你的闺蜜，不得不告诉所有人，过去这几个月里，你独自撑下来了，真的让我难以置信。嗯，我必须说，有很多人帮我一起撑过了这段时间。我知道。我并不是一个人扛过来的。我知道你不是，但你表现得太勇敢、太优雅了。你知道的，如果说太多我又要哭了，但我还是希望你分享一下确诊之后的首要
steps after you were diagnosed. Yes. So the first thing was I had surgery in January. Then I did 12 rounds of chemotherapy. I had to do it every week. I completed that in May. And then I completed three weeks of radiation in July. And I like sharing those details, Angela, because those were things when I was diagnosed, when I was reading about other people's stories, I appreciated those details. So that's why I'm offering them now. I also want to say that I was recently
步骤。好的。所以第一步是我在一月份做了手术。接着我做了 12 个疗程的化疗。我必须每周做一次。我在五月份完成了化疗。然后我在七月份完成了为期三周的放疗。安吉拉，我很喜欢分享这些细节，因为当我刚确诊、在阅读别人的故事时，我特别感激这些具体的细节。这就是为什么我今天要将它们说出来。我还想说，我最近又做了
rescreened. I can very happily say that I am cancer-free. Cancer-free. Yes. I remember the day you told me that you were cancer free. I remember how emotional we were in that moment. It was tears, and we were so thankful to hear those words. How does it feel for you to finally share this? Well, it all still feels very surreal. Even as I'm saying this out loud,
重新筛查。我非常高兴地宣布，我已经战胜癌症了。战胜癌症了。是的。我记得你告诉我你已经战胜癌症的那天。我记得当时我们的情绪有多激动。全是泪水，听到那些话时我们感到无比感激。终于把这件事分享出来，你现在感觉怎么样？嗯，这一切听起来仍然非常不真实。即使我正大声把这些话说出来，
even after making this announcement, even after living through it, I can't believe it's true. I mean, it's just, it's one of those things that you just never think is going to happen to you. Yeah. I mean, for a long time after the diagnosis came down, Lee and I just kept thinking that this was some mistake on the paperwork. Yeah.
即使在发布了这个公告之后，甚至在亲身经历过之后，我还是不敢相信这是真的。我的意思是，这真的、这真的是那种你绝对不会认为会发生在自己身上的事情。是的。我的意思是，在确诊后的很长一段时间里，我和李都一直觉得这只是病历文件上的某种失误。是的。
I remember just saying to you, like, are they sure? Yeah. And, you know, I am still receiving treatments. There are things that are designed to keep me cancer free. So I get an infusion every three weeks of a drug that's called Herceptin. I'm also taking a drug each day to block my body from absorbing estrogen.
我记得我当时对你说：“他们确定吗？”是的。而且，你知道，我仍在接受治疗。有些药物是为了防止癌症复发而设计的。所以我每三周要输液一次，药物叫做赫赛汀。我每天还要吃一种药，用来阻止我的身体吸收雌激素。
So I'm still riding waves of super fun random side effects. But I am over the hump of the big treatments and I'm feeling more hearty and I really wanted to share my story in case it can help other women. Really that's what it's about for me. Yeah. We talked a lot about how you wanted to go through your treatment with privacy and how important it was. All I could think about during this time, Jenna, was that I just wanted to protect you,
所以我现在还在经历那些超级有趣、随机出现的副作用的浪潮。但我已经熬过了重大治疗的高峰期，感觉身体更硬朗了。我真的很想分享我的故事，以防它能帮到其他女性。对我来说，这才是最重要的。是的。我们曾多次聊过，你是如何希望低调完成治疗，以及这有多么重要。在那段时间里，珍娜，我脑子里想的全都是我只想保护你，
you know, and I wanted you to be able to focus all of your energy on your treatment and healing. And I knew that when you were ready that there would be a time for sharing. And I also know that you sharing is going to help so many people. And now you're ready to share. Yeah, I mean, I did need that bubble. Yeah. I did need to focus all my energy on my treatment and my family. I have kids. You have young kids and this was really that time where you just needed the space to heal. Yes.
你知道的，我希望你能把所有的精力都集中在治疗和康复上。我也知道，当你准备好的时候，自然会有分享的时机。而且我也深知，你的分享将会帮助到许多人。现在你准备好分享了。是的，我的确需要那个保护罩。是的。我确实需要把所有的精力都集中在治疗和我的家人身上。我有孩子。你有年幼的孩子，而那确实是你最需要空间去疗愈的时期。是的。
And to put your health first, do you want to tell everyone how you found out? Yeah. I also want to say, Angela, you are a great protector. I lost my hair during chemotherapy, and I was wearing these hats with fake hair coming out the back to all of our podcast recordings, all of our meetings. You guys, Angela started wearing hats to all our meetings too.
并且把健康放在第一位。你想告诉大家你是怎么发现的吗？是的。我还要说，安吉拉，你真的是个伟大的守护者。我在化疗期间掉了头发，在我们所有的播客录制和会议中，我都戴着后面有假发的帽子。大家伙儿，安吉拉后来也开始戴着帽子去参加我们所有的会议了。
We became the Hat Gals, and it was really moving to me, Angela. This was your idea. Angela also came over to my house, and she stayed with my kids during my surgery so that they didn't have to go to school that day. And it just meant so much to me that they were with you. Well... I could go on and on about all the ways have to go to school that day. And it just meant so much to me that they were with you. Well.
我们成了“帽子女孩”，这让我非常感动，安吉拉。这主意是你想出来的。安吉拉甚至还来到我家，在我手术期间陪着我的孩子们，这样他们那天就不用去上学了。能让他们跟你在一起，对我的意义实在是太重大了。嗯……我可以滔滔不绝地讲……天那天就不用去上学了。能让他们跟你在一起，对我的意义实在是太重大了。嗯。
I could go on and on about all the ways that Angela and Josh supported us during this time. But to answer your question about how I found out, it was through my routine mammogram. And by the way, that test was inconclusive, because I have really dense breast tissue. So my doctor ordered a follow-up ultrasound, and that is when they found the tumor.
我可以滔滔不绝地讲安吉拉和乔希在这期间支持我们的种种方式。但回答你关于我是怎么发现的问题，我是通过例行乳腺钼靶检查发现的。顺便说一下，那次检查的结果是不确定的，因为我的乳腺组织非常致密。所以我的医生开了一单后续的超声检查，也就是在那时他们发现了肿瘤。
It was in my left breast. It was too small to feel on a physical exam. So I don't know exactly how my sharing can be of service, but maybe this is your reminder out there to schedule your mammogram, because it was that routine appointment that caught my cancer early enough that it had not spread, and it was more easily treatable. It's so important. It's something you and I have talked about a lot,
它在我的左乳。肿瘤太小了，在体格检查中根本摸不到。所以我不知道我的分享到底能帮到什么忙，但也许这就是对大家的提醒，去预约你的乳腺钼靶检查吧，因为正是那次例行预约，足够早地发现了我的癌症，当时它还没有扩散，因此也更容易治疗。这太重要了。这是你和我讨论过很多次的事情，
that, you know, it's easy to put those things off and to put yourself second. You take care of everyone else, you put yourself second. And I remember after you were diagnosed that you, you know, I was just amazed by you, Jenna, because you just did that thing that you always do, which is you immediately wanted to get as much information as possible? Yeah, I mean, I was scared. And the thing that made me feel better was that information gathering. I really scoured the internet looking for any information I could find about my diagnosis. I read interviews and cancer blogs and Reddit threads. I got connected with an amazing team of doctors and nurses.
你知道的，人们总是很容易把这些事情一拖再拖，把自己排在第二位。你照顾了所有人，却把自己放在第二位。我记得在你确诊之后，你知道的，珍娜，你真的让我惊叹，因为你做了你一贯会做的事——那就是你立刻想要尽可能多地收集信息？对，我的确很害怕。而让我感觉好一点的事情就是收集信息。我真的在互联网上四处搜寻，寻找任何能找到的关于我的诊断的信息。我阅读采访、癌症博客和红迪网的帖子。我和一个了不起的医生和护士团队取得了联系。
They have been so patient and explained things over and over again until I understand them. Their patience is amazing. And then I got connected to other women who had had breast cancer and they helped me and I really want to pay that forward. So this is just the start. I hope to share more about my journey in the future. But right now, lady, we have a re-watch to finish. We do because I love doing our podcast. I love it so much and I want to say thank you to you and to Sam and Cassie. I just think that the space that we have here to work in,
他们非常有耐心，一遍又一遍地向我解释，直到我听懂为止。他们的耐心太惊人了。后来我还联系了其他得过乳腺癌的女性，她们给予了我帮助，我也真的很想把这份爱传递下去。所以这只是个开始。我希望在未来能分享更多关于我的抗癌历程。但现在，亲爱的，我们还有一个回看节目要完成呢。确实如此，因为我太喜欢做我们的播客了。我太爱它了，我想对你、对山姆和卡茜表达感谢。我觉得我们拥有这样一个可以并肩工作的小天地，
I am so lucky to have. And I know I'm lucky. Going through cancer treatment requires a lot of flexibility. This job afforded me a lot of flexibility. And more than that, though, it gave me a safe place to come and laugh and escape. I felt a sense of purpose here. It is important to me and I cannot thank you all enough. And this is a thank you to our Office Ladies community as well for this space existing, I guess.
我真的是太幸运了。我知道我很幸运。经历癌症治疗需要极大的灵活性。这份工作赋予了我极大的灵活性。不过，更重要的是，它给了我一个可以来到这里欢笑、逃离现实的安全港湾。我在这里感受到了使命感。这对我来说意义重大，我对你们感激不尽。这也是对我们“办公室女士”社区的感谢，感谢这个小天地的存在，我想是的。
And I like being in it. And we have a really good episode today. I want everyone to hear it and enjoy it. Well, lady, we love you. And we are here for you. And I'm gonna give you a hug, but I bet there's lots of other folks just sending you virtual hugs as you share.
而且我很喜欢身处其中。我们今天有一集非常精彩的节目。我想让每个人都听一听、乐一乐。好了，亲爱的，我们爱你。我们一直都在你身边。我要给你一个大大的拥抱，但我敢肯定，当你们分享这些时，还有许多其他人也在向你发送虚拟拥抱。
And you're right, we have a great episode and you're so good in it. So let's hear it. Here it is everyone, AARM part one. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends.
你说的对，我们有一集很棒的节目，你在里面的表现太棒了。让我们一起来听听吧。这就是今天的内容，AARM 第一部分。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。
And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Hello. Hi.
现在我们专门为你制作了终极办公室重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并送上只有身临其境的当事人才知道的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。大家好。嗨。
We have a big, big episode today. I mean, the next four are big. That's right. It's AARM Part 1, Season 9, Episode 24, written by Brent Forrester and directed by Dave Rogers. And here is your summary. The group readies themselves for the premiere of the documentary.
我们今天有一集非常非常重磅的节目。我的意思是，接下来四集都很重磅。没错。这就是《AARM》第一部分，第九季第二十四集，由布伦特·福斯特编剧，戴夫·罗杰斯执导。以下是本集梗概：众人正为纪录片的首播做准备。
Wow, it's really happening. It's happening. Dwight is going to conduct a series of challenges because he needs an assistant to his assistant. That's the AARM, Assistant to the Assistant Regional Manager. And Jim's having a great time, but Pam wonders if Jim staying in Scranton for her is a mistake. Meanwhile, Dwight reveals his plan to propose to Esther, Darryl tries to Irish exit from
哇，这真的要发生了。要发生了。德怀特将进行一系列的挑战，因为他需要一个“助理的助理”。这就是 AARM，即地区经理助理的助理。吉姆玩得很开心，但帕姆纳闷吉姆为了她留在斯克兰顿是不是个错误。与此同时，德怀特透露了向埃丝特求婚的计划，达里尔试图从邓德米夫林
Dunder Mifflin, Andy lines up to audition for a TV singing competition, and Angela and Oscar bring Philip to work and sort of co-parent him. Yeah. A lot is happening. They're actually a really good team. They really are. Well before we dive in I'll have you know I am using a mug today that is maybe my new, not maybe, it is my new favorite mug of all time. It's the cutest thing. I've never seen anything like it. Tell us about it Jenna. Alright we went through our fan mail and this was in there. It is a handmade mug by this gal named Katie, C-A-T-I-E, and it is a
“爱尔兰式隐退”，安迪排队参加电视歌唱比赛的试镜，安吉拉和奥斯卡把菲利普带到公司，并某种程度上共同抚养他。是的。发生了好多事。他们其实是一个非常棒的团队。他们真的是。在我们深入探讨之前，我想让你们知道，我今天用的这个马克杯可能是我全新的——不是可能，它绝对是我有生以来最喜欢的全新马克杯。太可爱了。我从没见过这样的。跟我们讲讲它吧，珍娜。好的，我们翻看粉丝来信时发现了这个。这是由一个叫凯蒂的女孩手工制作的马克杯，名字拼写是 C-A-T-I-E，它是一个
mug with pockets. It looks like denim. Mm-hmm. With the stitching and there's all these little denim pockets. And you know I love to drink my coffee out of a handmade piece. I know. It just brings me joy in the mornings. We should also say that Katie made me a mug as well and it has hummingbirds on it. Yes. Does she get us or what? She definitely gets us. Katie wrote us the sweetest letter, Angela. She said that she is from my hometown of St. Louis, born and raised, although she does not say fardy far. Not like Phyllis.
带口袋的马克杯。它看起来就像牛仔布。嗯哼。上面有缝线，还有所有这些小牛仔口袋。你知道我喜欢用手工艺品喝咖啡。我懂的。它在早晨带给我好心情。我们还应该说，凯蒂也给我做一个马克杯，上面有蜂鸟图案。是的。她太懂我们了吧？她绝对懂我们。凯蒂给我们写了一封最甜蜜的信，安吉拉。她说她来自我的家乡圣路易斯，土生土长，虽然她说话不带“fardy far”的口音。不像菲利斯那样。
No. Okay. She currently lives outside of St. Louis, but pottery is her passion. And Katie, I can see why. You are so good at it, Katie. We love these mugs. So incredibly talented.
没有。好吧。她目前住在圣路易斯郊外，但陶艺是她的激情所在。凯蒂，我能理解为什么了。你太擅长这个了，凯蒂。我们爱死这些马克杯了。简直太有才华了。
And I want to give her a shout out, but Katie, unless I'm missing something, I do not see an email address. I do not see her last name. I do not see an Instagram handle. We are looking for you. We are looking for you. So Katie, if you hear this,
我想对她大加赞赏一番，但是凯蒂，除非我漏掉了什么，我没有看到电子邮件地址。我没有看到她的姓氏。我没有看到她的 Instagram 账号。我们在找你。我们在找我们。所以凯蒂，如果你听到这个，
or anyone that knows Katie in St. Louis that made us coffee mugs with amazing hummingbirds and pockets, will you tell Katie we love them and we'd love to give her a proper shout out? Well, I know that I have not had a big soap box in a while. Do you have one? I might have one. Is it about the Jim and Pam storyline?
或者任何认识这位在圣路易斯、给我们制作了印有惊艳蜂鸟图案和口袋的咖啡马克杯的凯蒂的人，能告诉凯蒂我们很爱它们，并且很想给她一个大大的赞赏吗？好吧，我知道我有一段时间没有长篇大论了。你有吗？我可能有一个。是关于吉姆和帕姆的故事线的吗？
It is. Is it going to be fast fact one? It's not. I'm saving it for later, but I'm prepping because I feel like this is my mug for soap boxes now. You got your pockets mug. I do. My FastFag 1 is that AARM Part 1 aired on May 9th, 2013.
是的。这会是“趣事一”吗？不是。我把它留到后面再说，但我现在在做准备，因为我觉得这就是我以后的“长篇大论专属马克杯”。你拿到了你的口袋杯。我拿到了。我的“趣事一”是：《AARM》第一部分于 2013 年 5 月 9 日播出。
And remember how we said that Diversity Day was like the pilot after the pilot? Well, this was considered the finale before the finale. This was really the last time we're going to see all of these characters in this chronological real time, because the finale is going to flash forward in time. That's right. Well, this episode was also very well received by critics and fans.
还记得我们是怎么说过《多元化日》就像是试播集之后的试播集吗？嗯，这一集就被认为是结局之前的结局。这确实是我们最后一次在真实的纪年时间里看到所有这些角色，因为大结局将会把时间闪回未来。没错。这一集也受到了评论家和粉丝的一致好评。
Jenna Mullins of E! Online said that it was, quote, full of emotional moments that seemed like love letters to fans who have watched the show since the pilot, which is really what Greg was going for in these, especially, last few episodes. But do you remember how it was Greg's intention to bring back different cast members throughout the last season?
E! Online 的珍娜·穆林斯说它，引述一下，“充满了情感时刻，就像是写给自试播集以来就一直在看这档节目的粉丝的情书”，这确实是格雷格在这些尤其最后几集里想要达到的效果。但你们还记得格雷格的初衷是想在最后一季中让不同的演员回归吗？
How we've seen Roy, Jan, all of Dwight's crazy friends. Todd Packer. Mm-hmm. Well, he also wanted to make sure that we had an episode that featured that classic Jim Dwight dynamic. That is what inspired this episode. You know, Jim's been gone.
就像我们看到了罗伊、简、德怀特所有的疯狂朋友。托德·帕克。嗯哼。好吧，他还想确保我们能有一集呈现出那种经典的吉姆和德怀特动态的节目。这就是这一集的灵感来源。你知道，吉姆一直不在。
We haven't had this playful Jim Dwight business. Yeah. And so that is what inspired this episode. Well, I love Dwight and Jim, you know, so it made me very happy to see them in their shenanigans again. And now, fast fact number two, Angela, I'm handing it over to you.
我们一直没有这种好玩的吉姆和德怀特的对手戏。是的。所以这就是这一集的灵感来源。我非常喜欢德怀特和吉姆，所以看到他们再次胡闹让我非常开心。现在，趣事之二，安吉拉，我把它交给你了。
Thank you. So I'm going to do fast fact two and three today. Here's fast fact number two. A few things. This episode is the start of the final DVD in the whole box set. We're on the last DVD. It's disc number five, season nine. Here are the bonus features on it. There are season nine bloopers, the final table read of the whole series. Yeah, that'll tug on the heartstrings. The 2003 casting auditions of the cast and an auto-tune version of Andy's audition song from this episode. I have a few really fun things from my digital clutter that I will be
谢谢。所以我今天要讲趣事二和趣事三。这是趣事之二。有几件事。这一集是整个套装中最后一张 DVD 的开始。我们到最后一张 DVD 了。它是第九季的第五碟。以下是上面的花絮。有第九季的NG镜头，整个剧集的最后一次剧本围读。是的，那会触动心弦的。演员们 2003 年的选角试镜，以及本集中安迪试镜歌曲的自动调音版本。我有几件来自我数字杂物堆里的趣事，我会
sprinkling into AARM part one and two. Here's the first one. Per my emails that I clearly never get rid of, guess what we were doing this week? What were we doing? I'll give you a hint. What? It's also on the call sheets. We were filming the interviews for the office a look Back. Yes, of course. You know, when I rewatched this episode, I immediately flashed to us sitting in Caffeine Corner doing those interviews between scenes. In fact, I specifically remember
把它们穿插进《AARM》第一部分和第二部分中。这是第一件。根据我显然永远不会删掉的电子邮件，你们猜我们这周在做什么？我们在做什么？我给你们个提示。什么？它也写在通告单上。我们在拍摄《办公室：回眸》的采访。对，当然。你知道的，当我重温这一集时，我的脑海里立刻闪现出我们坐在咖啡角在场景之间进行那些采访的画面。事实上，我清楚地记得
walking out of the warehouse set where we're doing the whole obstacle course and doing those interviews. Well, you know, John organized the filming of this. It's actually all on disc four, but they're so great. They really capture where we all were in our minds and in our hearts as we were filming this episode. And I thought we should play some.
走出我们正在拍摄整个障碍训练场的仓库布景，然后去做那些采访。你知道的，约翰组织了这次拍摄。其实这些都在第四碟里，但它们太棒了。它们真正捕捉到了我们在拍摄这一集时，大家心里和脑海里的真实状态。我觉得我们应该放一些出来听听。
Oh, I love this. You know, they really got a combination of cast, writers, crew, talking about their time on the office. And then it aired on NBC before the finale. That's right. All right, so now for fast fact number three, and I'm going to share clips from A Look Back every week until we finish the rewatch. And for this episode, my first clip is us all sort of pondering, what is this show?
哦，我太喜欢这个了。你知道，他们真的收集了演员、编剧和剧组人员的组合，谈论他们在《办公室》的时光。然后在结局之前在 NBC 播出。没错。好了，现在是趣事之三，在我们的重温结束之前，我每周都会分享来自《回眸》的片段。对于这一集，我的第一个片段是我们所有人都在思索：这到底是一部什么剧？
Oh, I like it. It was simple. It was just an office. Very little happened at Dunder Mifflin. They didn't really get much work done. It is a quintessential American workplace comedy show. It was awkward, painfully awkward and hilarious. We've all had a boss. They get in the way of you doing your job. I just love how real it was.
哦，我喜欢这个。很简单。它只是一个办公室。邓德米夫林公司没发生什么大事。他们其实没干多少活。这是一部典型的美国职场喜剧。它很尴尬，令人痛苦地尴尬又滑稽。我们都遇到过老板。他们会妨碍你工作。我只是喜欢它有多真实。
We were everybody's experience at work. It celebrated those human interactions that annoy us all and make us chuckle or make us mad. I think that's what allows people to connect to the show, because they can see themselves, they can see their jobs, they can see their relationships in this show. The premise of the show when we started was, what if you had the world's worst boss? And the irony was this is a guy who bought a mug for himself that said world's best boss.
我们展现了所有人的职场体验。它赞美了那些让我们所有人感到恼火、让我们哑然失笑或让我们生气的各种人际互动。我认为这就是让人们能够与这部剧产生共鸣的原因，因为他们可以在这部剧中看到自己，看到自己的工作，看到自己的人际关系。当我们刚开始时，这部剧的设定是：如果你有个世界上最糟糕的老板会怎么样？而讽刺的是，这是一个给自己买了个马克杯、上面写着“世界上最好的老板”的家伙。
And then later in the clip, I really thought BJ sums up the show really well. Let's hear it. Who could not relate to the show? The guy wants the girl but can't have her. There's a weirdo working next to you and your boss is insane. Yeah, that is it. Is that perfect?
然后在短片的后面，我真的觉得 BJ 对这部剧的总结非常精辟。我们来听听。谁能不跟这部剧共情呢？一个男的想要这个女孩却得不到。你旁边坐着一个怪人，而且你的老板是个疯子。是的，就是这样。这难道不完美吗？
That is perfect. All right. Well, I'll be sharing a few more things from my digital clutter throughout this episode and the next one, plus some more clips from that look back. Wow. I can't believe that we're really getting to the end, Angela.
这简直太完美了。好了。在这集和下一集里，我还将从我的数字杂物堆里分享更多东西，再加上更多来自那个回眸特辑的片段。哇。真不敢相信我们真的要走到最后了，安吉拉。
I know, you know, I was trading emails with Brent Forrester who wrote this episode and he said, oh my gosh. He said, I am having feelings. Is this the last time I get to share about the office with you guys? And I said, nope, no Brent, it's not. Yes. Did you tell him about Office Lady 6.0? And I said, nope, no, Brent, it's not. Yes. Did you tell him about Office Ladies 6.0?
我知道，你知道的，我一直在和编写这一集的布伦特·福斯特发邮件交流，他说：“哦天哪。”他说：“我百感交集。这是我最后一次能和你们一起分享关于《办公室》的感受了吗？”我说：“不，不是的，布伦特，还早着呢。”是的。你告诉他关于“办公室女士 6.0”的事了吗？我说：“不，不是的，布伦特，还早着呢。”是的。你告诉他关于“办公室女士 6.0”的事了吗？
Yes, I did. I said, Brent, don't you worry, we're not going anywhere. No, Brent, we are still going to be emailing you constantly. We promise. And I know we shared about this at the top of our show last week, but for anyone who missed it, after we are done breaking down all of the office episodes,
是的，我说了。我说：“布伦特，别担心，我们哪儿也不去。”“不，布伦特，我们还是会不断给你发邮件的。我们保证。”我知道我们在上周节目的开头分享过这个，但对于任何错过的人来说，在我们剖析完所有的《办公室》剧集之后，
we will be busting out office ladies 6.0. I love it I love the title. I love it so much. You guys know the reference when Katie the purse girl comes into the office during hot girl Michael calls her Pam 6.0. Jenna and I were talking about this we think it's because there was an iPhone 5 at the time or like a Microsoft something there was something 5 at the time. Or like a Microsoft something, 5? There was something 5. Something 5.
我们将重磅推出“办公室女士 6.0”。我太喜欢了，我太喜欢这个名字了。我爱极了。你们都知道这个梗：当背包女孩凯蒂在“辣妹”那一集走进办公室时，迈克尔叫她“帕姆 6.0”。珍娜和我讨论过这个，我们觉得这是因为当时有 iPhone 5，或者是微软的什么产品，当时有个叫 5 的东西。或者微软的什么产品，5？当时有个叫 5 的东西。某个 5。
At the time. But it just tickles us so much that we are now gonna be Office Ladies 6.0. And basically, we're gonna keep chatting about the office. We're gonna dig deeper into characters and storylines, webisodes, themes, we're gonna interview people, and of course, there will be plenty of best friend banter, deep dives, soap boxes, I'm sure.
那个时候。但这个梗让我们觉得太有趣了，以至于我们现在要变成“办公室女士 6.0”了。基本上，我们将继续畅聊《办公室》。我们将更深入地挖掘角色和剧情线、网络短剧、主题，我们会采访嘉宾，当然，还会有大量的闺蜜闲聊、深度剖析、长篇大论，我敢肯定。
What? More soap boxes? Possibly. And for all of you that love rewatching the show over and over and re-listening to our breakdown of the episodes, don't you worry, because we are going to rerun the entire rewatch in order every Monday from the beginning. And guess what we're calling that? Second drink. Second drink, isn't that perfect? Yeah, we're gonna pop on each week with some bonus tidbits.
什么？还有长篇大论？有可能。对于所有喜欢一遍又一遍重温这部剧、一遍又一遍听我们剖析剧集的你们，别担心，因为我们将从头开始，在每个星期一按顺序重播整个重温节目。你们猜我们管这叫什么？第二杯。第二杯，这难道不完美吗？是的，我们每周都会带着一些额外的花絮闪亮登场。
You know, there are people who tell me that they just found the podcast. Yeah, and we've been breaking it down for five years, but people are discovering it and we wanna been breaking it down for five years, but people are discovering it and we want to make sure it's there for them. Well, I know, for example, in the UK, they just got the Office on Netflix. So for anybody who wants to re-listen or start listening, we'll be starting our second drink on November 11th.
你知道的，有些人告诉我他们刚刚发现这个播客。是的，我们已经剖析了五年了，但人们仍在发现它，我们想要确保它一直都在那里为他们服务。好吧，我知道，例如在英国，他们刚刚在 Netflix 上线了《办公室》。所以对于任何想要重新收听或开始收听的人，我们将于 11 月 11 日开始我们的“第二杯”。
And Office Ladies 6.0 starts on November 6th. All right. Why don't we go to break? But before we do, real quick, I have one more thing, you guys. You know I love some seasonal clothing. Uh-huh. Okay, so I saw some really cute Halloween socks that feature little cats, and I got us all a pair.
而“办公室女士 6.0”将于 11 月 6 日开始。好啦。我们为什么不休息一下呢？但在我们这样做之前，快点，伙计们，我还有一件事。你们知道我喜欢应季服装。嗯哼。好吧，我看到一些非常可爱的万圣节袜子，上面有小猫咪，我给我们每人都买了一双。
Aw, thanks, lady. This is what happens to me when I'm alone in a shopping mall. I'm like, oh, cat socks, I'll buy those. Well, I want to give you fair warning. I've been saving Instagram videos of Halloween crafts that you can make from Dollar Tree. So please tell me we can make one. OK.
噢，谢谢你，亲爱的。这就是我独自在购物中心时会发生的事情。我会想：“哦，猫咪袜子，我要买这些。”好吧，我想先给你打个预防针。我一直在保存万圣节手工制作的 Instagram 视频，你可以用一元店的东西来做。所以请告诉我我们可以做一个。好吧。
We might be crafting one Saturday soon. You guys each get to pick out a pair. Sam, it said one size fits all. I don't know. But maybe they'll fit everybody. All right. Let's take a break and we will be back with AARM Part 1. We are back. We have cute Halloween cat socks and we are ready to break down this episode. Kevin is going to arrive to work. He waves at Aaron. There's a very sophisticated sort
我们可能很快就会在某个周六做手工。你们每个人都可以挑一双。山姆，上面写着均码。我不知道。但也许它们适合所有人。好吧。我们休息一下，马上回来继续《AARM》第一部分。我们回来了。我们有可爱的万圣节猫咪袜子，我们准备好剖析这一集了。凯文来上班了。他向艾琳挥手。发生了一种非常复杂的
of like keypad buzzer thing happening. He buzzes the keypad and Aaron says the tea in Nepal is very hot. And Kevin has written some kind of like passcode on his arm and he answers, but the coffee in Peru is much hotter. And then Aaron lets him in. Dwight has a talking head where he explains he has made some upgrades to the office security. He got these new doors from an old jewelry store. He has this passcode that he sends everybody first thing in the morning. It's not the KGB, but it's a start. He loves to lock it up. He loves a tight security system. And then he arrives to work and he gets the code wrong and then they hit the
类似于键盘蜂鸣器的东西。他按了键盘，艾琳说：“尼泊尔的茶非常热。”凯文在手臂上写了某种密码，他回答说：“但是秘鲁的咖啡要热得多。”然后艾琳让他进去了。德怀特有一个访谈镜头，他解释说他给办公室安保做了一些升级。他从一家旧珠宝店弄到了这些新门。他有一个每天一大早发给每个人的密码。这不是克格勃，但这只是个开始。他喜欢把它锁起来。他热爱严密的安保系统。然后他来上班了，结果密码输错了，接着他们就按下了
steam button. Dwight says it's harmless steam to scare intruders, although he wanted dangerous steam, I guess, but it was too expensive. Creed likes it. He's, I think, been purposely steaming the room because it's saving him on dry cleaning. Now we have our opening credits. They're very short, but we got a lot of mail about them. I bet I can guess. Yeah.
蒸汽按钮。德怀特说这是用来吓唬入侵者的无害蒸汽，尽管他本来想要危险的蒸汽，我猜，但太贵了。克里德很喜欢。他大概一直在故意制造蒸汽，因为这能省下他的干洗费。现在是我们的开场字幕。它们非常短，但我们收到了很多关于它们的邮件。我敢打赌我能猜到。是的。
We have a new manager. Where are our new credits? What little bobblehead thing would Dwight have pushed to the front? Angela, you are not the only person who is disappointed. Let me read this one from Jesse B. in San Clemente, California, who said, we have been waiting as long as Dwight has for him to be manager. So now that he is finally manager, why does he not get the ending manager slot in the intro? I know. Well, we reached out to Dave Rogers,
我们有新经理了。我们的新片头在哪里？德怀特会把哪个小摇头娃娃推到最前面？安吉拉，你不是唯一一个失望的人。让我读一下这位来自加利福尼亚州圣克莱门特的杰西 B. 的信，她说：“我们等待德怀特成为经理等了和他一样长的时间。所以既然他终于成了经理，为什么他在片头里没有得到最后的经理专属位置？”我懂的。好吧，我们联系了戴夫·罗杰斯，
director of this episode. We asked him a bunch of questions, and this is the first one. Dave said that there was discussion about adding a Dwight as manager shot at the end of this title sequence, but ultimately they never filmed anything new for it and here is why. The main reason was they wanted to use Pam and Jim kissing as the final image in the main title for several episodes because they felt that at this point, the idea of who is manager had been eclipsed by the characters personal lives.
这一集的导演。我们问了他一堆问题，这是第一个。戴夫说，曾讨论过在这个片头序列的结尾加入一个“经理德怀特”的镜头，但最终他们从未为此拍摄任何新东西，原因如下。主要原因是他们希望在几集的主片头中使用帕姆和吉姆接吻作为最后一个画面，因为他们觉得在这一点上，“谁是经理”这个概念已经被角色的个人生活所掩盖了。
And they felt like the focus here of these final episodes was more about summing up Jim and Pam. He said also they were really pressed for time and they literally didn't have time to shoot a new little manager title with Dwight. And also there was so much in this episode that they had to make the main titles really short anyway. So there were kind of three reasons. I was thinking it was for time that we were just really crunching to get these episodes out and they were such big episodes as it was. There's a whole entire Nellie and Toby
而且他们觉得这些最后几集的焦点更多在于总结吉姆和帕姆。他还说，他们的时间非常紧迫，简直没有时间为德怀特拍摄一个新的经理片头。而且这一集里有太多内容，无论如何他们都得把主片头剪得很短。所以大概有三个原因。我本以为是因为时间关系，我们真的在赶时间把这些集赶出来，而且它们本身就是这么大的大制作。这里面有整整一条内莉和托比的
storyline that is cut. I know. So they really needed to use every second and minute they had for this episode. I'm going to tell you something right now. I would have preferred to see Dwight at the end of these end credits rather than Jim and Pam. And this is going to relate to my soapbox later. But Jim and Pam are on my last nerve right now. Okay. So, stay tuned for the soapbox. Stay tuned. Next up, we are in Oscar's apartment.
故事线被删掉了。我懂的。所以他们真的需要把这一集拥有的每一秒每一分钟都利用起来。我现在就告诉你们。我宁愿在片尾字幕的最后看到德怀特，而不是吉姆和帕姆。这与我稍后的长篇大论有关。但吉姆和帕姆现在让我烦透了。好吧。所以，请继续收听接下来的长篇大论。敬请期待。接下来，我们来到奥斯卡的公寓。
And there is a very interesting sleeping arrangement going on here. It looks like Oscar's apartment has sort of a main bedroom, and on either side of the bedroom, there are two walk-in closets. This is very nice closet storage. Baby Philip is in a crib in one walk-in closet and on the other side of the bedroom, Angela is sleeping in the other side.
这里正在进行一种非常有趣的睡眠安排。看起来奥斯卡的公寓有一个类似的主卧室，在卧室的两侧，有两个步入式衣帽间。这里的衣帽间储物空间非常棒。小菲利普在一个步入式衣帽间的婴儿床里，而在卧室的另一侧，安吉拉睡在另一边。
Yes. Lady, I love these Angela and Oscar roommate scenes so much and I want to take a moment to appreciate how amazing Oscar's loft looks. It was built entirely on our stage. Our art department and set dressing did such a fantastic job. Here is my digital clutter item number two. I call it a loft because that is what our art department called it.
是的。亲爱的，我太喜欢这些安吉拉和奥斯卡的室友场景了，我想花点时间欣赏一下奥斯卡的高级公寓看起来有多棒。它完全是在我们的舞台上搭建的。我们的美术部门和布景装潢做得太出色了。这是我的数字杂物件之二。我叫它loft（公寓），因为那是我们美术部门叫它的。
At the time, I was remodeling my own house and redoing my kitchen, and I loved the kitchen they built for Oscar so much, I asked them if I could have some photos of it. And one of our set dressers, James, aka Jim McDermott, we love him, sent me all the photos of Oscar's entire loft. I still have them, I found them, and I'm going to share them in stories. This is a gorgeous, gorgeous loft. I'll tell you two things that I noticed, two background catches that really impressed me, and I felt like they were great details. Let's hear it.
当时，我在装修我自己的房子并重做厨房，我太喜欢他们为奥斯卡搭建的厨房了，以至于我问他们能不能给我一些照片。我们的一个布景师詹姆斯，也就是吉姆·麦克德莫特，我们都很爱他，把奥斯卡整个公寓的所有照片都发给了我。我仍然留着它们，我把它们找出来了，我会在快讯里分享。这是一个华丽至极的公寓。我告诉你们我注意到的两件事，两个让我印象深刻、觉得是非常棒的细节的背景抓拍。我们听听。
At two minutes and six seconds, Oscar has a red landline rotary phone on his bedside table. You know he does. You know he's a landline guy. He's ready. He's ready. He is ready. And then at two minutes and 11 seconds he has a red canister set in his kitchen. Mm-hmm. He clearly loves a pop of red. He loves a pop of color. I love these details. Well, Philip is gonna cry and Oscar tells Angela he's crying for her. They're getting ready for work. It's kind of like that busy morning where you're getting kids out the door. Angela's laying out Philip's outfit and Oscar says saddle shoes with denim. I will literally call child services. So Oscar is like
在两分零六秒时，奥斯卡的床头柜上有一部红色的老式转盘固定电话。你知道他有。你知道他是固定电话派。他准备好了。他准备好了。他准备好了。然后在两分十一秒时，他的厨房里有一套红色的罐子。嗯哼。他显然对红色情有独钟。他喜欢亮眼的颜色。我喜欢这些细节。好吧，菲利普哭了，奥斯卡告诉安吉拉他是为了她才哭的。他们正准备去上班。这有点像那种急着把孩子送出门的忙碌早晨。安吉拉正在给菲利普摆好衣服，奥斯卡说“马鞍鞋配牛仔布，我简直要报警了”。所以奥斯卡就像是
helping Philip's look. And I just love doing all of these scenes. They felt so easy and organic for these two characters to be roommates. This is definitely one of my favorite Angela storylines ever. Yeah, me too. Is this pairing. Me too. Speaking of pairs, Esther has driven Dwight to work.
在帮菲利普把关造型。我太喜欢所有这些场景了。对于这两个角色来说，作为室友感觉是那么轻松和自然。这绝对是我最喜欢的安吉拉故事线之一。是的，我也是。就是这种搭配。我也是。说到搭配，埃丝特开车送德怀特去上班了。
Yeah. And they kiss goodbye. We learned some big news now in a Dwight talking head. You know, he's sort of listing off all the things that are going well for him. Manager of Dunder Mifflin, check. Owner of a 1,600 acre beet farm, check. Engaged to an actual milkmaid.
是的。他们吻别。现在我们在德怀特的访谈镜头中得知了一些重大的消息。你知道，他正在细数所有对他而言进展顺利的事情。邓德米夫林经理，搞定。1600 英亩甜菜农场主，搞定。跟一个真正的挤奶女工订婚。
Well, almost check, right? That's going to happen later in the day. He's going to propose to her with his grandmother's ring from her butt. Well, from a bullet from her butt. A bullet from her butt. Yeah. Yeah.
嗯，算是快搞定了吧？那会在稍后发生。他要用他祖母从屁股里取出来的戒指向她求婚。好吧，是从她屁股里的子弹。从屁股里取出的子弹。对。对。
Next up, Andy is going to arrive to auditions for America's Next Acapella Sensation. He's checking in, and he seems nervous. Like, will I be allowed to audition? They're like no problem head to the back of the line he's like yes yes I mean he felt like he had to list off his resume so far he was like you might know me from a TV documentary that's premiering tonight I also killed it in local theater and I'm
接下来，安迪将抵达“美国下一代无伴奏合唱新星”的试镜现场。他在签到，看起来很紧张。比如：我能参加试镜吗？他们说：没问题，去队伍后面。他说：好，好，我的意思是，他觉得自己不得不列出到目前为止的履历，他说：你可能从今晚首播的电视纪录片里认识我，我在地方剧院里表现也炸裂，而且我刚接了一部火爆的工业片。是的，他们说：我们不在乎，老兄，快去排队吧。我问史蒂夫·伯吉斯我们在哪里拍摄的这条巨大的试镜队伍，他说我们在伯班克的皮克维克拍摄的，我们在他们会议室的外面和内部都拍了。皮克维克就像是一个保龄球馆和溜冰场。是的。他们把除了溜冰场以外的所有东西都拆了。洛杉矶国王队买下了溜冰场，而其余所有的东西——保龄球馆、剩下的所有东西、会议中心的小巷、其余所有的东西、会议中心都被拆了，他们正在那里盖公寓。你在开玩笑吧。
fresh off a hot industrial flick yeah they're like we don't care buddy just go get in line. I asked Steve Burgess where did we shoot this giant audition line he said we shot at Pickwick in Burbank we shot outside and inside their convention center. Pickwick is like a bowling alley and ice skating rink. It was. They tore down everything except the ice skating rink. The LA Kings purchased the ice rink and all the rest of it the bowling alley all the rest of it the convention center alley, all the rest of it, the convention center has been torn down and they're putting up condos. You are kidding me.
我太喜欢那个保龄球馆了。等等，我一直在那里打保龄球。那是我的保龄球馆。是的。哦，我不知道这个。这有点像洛杉矶的……我不知道。我觉得它很有标志性。
I loved that bowling alley. Wait, I bowled there constantly all the time. That was my bowling alley. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, I didn't know that. It was kind of like an LA, I don't know. I feel like it was iconic.
是的。皮克维克。皮克维克。是的。我们收到了来自纽约州韦伯斯特的亚当 W. 的粉丝提问，他说：“在 3 分 36 秒时，当安迪走向队尾时，这个场景里到底有多少群演？”这里有太多了。我也想知道。这队伍看起来像是绵延到永远。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说 234 个。
Yeah. Pickwick. Pickwick. Yeah. We got a fan question from Adam W. in Webster, New York, who said, At 3 minutes 36 seconds when Andy is walking to the back of the line, exactly how many extras were in this scene? There are so many. I wondered the same thing. The line looks like it goes on forever. Steve Burges said 234.
这对我们来说简直是个天文数字。这太多了。我们还收到了来自澳大利亚悉尼的尼基 C. 的粉丝提问，他问：“为什么纪录片摄制组在安迪离开办公室后还要继续跟随他？他们可没跟着迈克尔、罗伯特·加州或任何其他人。”嗯。猜猜谁能为我们解答？戴夫·罗杰斯。没错。戴夫说，这个剧集设定内的答案很简单。
That's a ton for us. That's a lot. We also got a fan question from Nikita C. in Sydney, Australia who asked, why did the documentary crew continue to follow Andy after he left the office? They didn't follow Michael or Robert California or anyone else. Hmm. Guess who had an answer for us? Dave Rogers. That's right. Dave said the in-universe answer to this question is simple.
如果一个人搬得很远，不再与公司有羁绊，比如去科罗拉多的迈克尔或去欧洲的罗伯特·加州，那么纪录片摄制组就不再跟拍他们了。他们只是负担不起派摄制组去跟拍
If a person moved far away and was no longer tied to the company like Michael in Colorado or Robert, California in Europe, then the documentary crew no longer covered them. They just couldn't afford to send crews to follow these people. They did couldn't afford to send crews to follow
这些人的费用。不过，他们确实派摄制组去了塔拉哈西。因为我们的邓德米夫林员工去了。啊，就像斯坦福分公司一样。是的，塔拉哈西，足够多的员工去了。没错。他们依然隶属于邓德米夫林。明白了。他说，当迈克尔、帕姆和瑞恩创立迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司时，摄像机也跟着他们，因为他们还在本地。他们依然与斯克兰顿分公司盘根错节。他们也在同一栋大楼里。确实。
these people. They did send a crew to Tallahassee though. Because our Dunder Mifflin people went. Ah, like the Stanford branch. Yes, Tallahassee, enough of the employees, went. Correct. They were still affiliated with Dunder Mifflin. Got it. He said also the cameras still followed Michael, Pam, and Ryan when they formed Michael Scott Paper Company because they were still local. They were still intertwined with the Scranton branch. They were also in the same building. True.
但当安迪去佛罗里达散心时，摄像机也跟着他了。你知道吗？然而，当安迪和他的兄弟一起去他的船上航海时，摄制组并没有陪着他。所以，因为他只是最近才被解雇去追求他的歌唱梦想，纪录片摄制组觉得去一趟匹兹堡看看他是否能成功是值得跟拍的。我接受这个解释。我接受。这算是为他的故事画上了句号。
But the camera also followed Andy when he went to Florida to get air in. You know? However, when Andy went sailing on his boat with his brother, the crew did not stay with him. So because he was only very recently fired to pursue his dream of being a singer, the documentary crew felt that a trip to Pittsburgh to see if he was going to make it was worth following. I buy that. I buy that. It sort of wraps up his story.
但是，当安迪去佛罗里达散心时，摄像机也一路跟随。你知道吗？不过，当安迪和他的兄弟一起乘船出海时，摄制组并没有跟他一起去。因此，由于他不久前才被解雇去追求成为歌手的梦想，纪录片摄制组觉得去匹兹堡看看他是否能成功是值得跟踪拍摄的。我接受这一点。我接受这一点。这算是为他的故事画上了句号。
And remember, he did spend a whole episode following his dream, not following his dream, I buy that. It sort of wraps up his story. And remember, he did spend a whole episode following his dream, not following his dream, following his dream. I think there is some value in knowing could he be back at Dunder Mifflin next week. Right, right. So that was how we explained it internally, why the camera is still with Andy.
And remember, he did spend a whole episode following his dream, not following his dream, I buy that. It sort of wraps up his story. And remember, he did spend a whole episode following his dream, not following his dream, following his dream. I think there is some value in knowing could he be back at Dunder Mifflin next week. Right, right. So that was how we explained it internally, why the camera is still with Andy.|||还记得吗，他确实花了一整集去追逐梦想，不是追逐梦想，我接受这个设定。这算是个结局。还记得吗，他确实花了一整集去追逐梦想，不是追逐梦想，追逐梦想。我觉得，探讨他下周是否能回到邓德米夫林，还是有一定价值的。对，没错。这就是我们内部解释的方式，为什么摄像机还在安迪身边。
I buy it. I buy it. Well, Andy is to have a talking head where he says he burned all of his bridges at Dunder Mifflin and it's time to become the next American Idol by winning America's next acapella sensation on channel TBD. I love that it was TBD to be determined. He said this is basically a new take on American Idol and The Voice because this time all three judges are mean. We now have a really great scene between Jim and Dwight and Dwight's office. Jim is going to give
I buy it. I buy it. Well, Andy is to have a talking head where he says he burned all of his bridges at Dunder Mifflin and it's time to become the next American Idol by winning America's next acapella sensation on channel TBD. I love that it was TBD to be determined. He said this is basically a new take on American Idol and The Voice because this time all three judges are mean. We now have a really great scene between Jim and Dwight and Dwight's office. Jim is going to give|||我接受。我接受。好吧，安迪有一段独白，他说自己在邓德米夫林已经断了所有后路，现在是时候通过赢得待定频道（TBD）的美国下一个阿卡贝拉轰动节目，成为下一个美国偶像了。我太喜欢那个“TBD”（待定）的梗了。他说这基本上是对《美国偶像》和《好声音》的一种全新诠释，因为这次三个评委都很刻薄。接下来是吉姆和德怀特在德怀特办公室里的一场精彩对手戏。吉姆要给
him a sales form to sign but first he has to put it in the inbox. He can't hand it to Dwight. No. He has to put it in the inbox then Dwight signs it then Dwight puts it in the outbox where then Jim can pick it up and then they shake but Jim does not let go of his hand. And then this goes into one of those classic great fakie talking heads where you think it's just Dwight but we reveal the sidekick and it's Jim sitting just behind him. Angela did you do a breakdown of Dwight's office decor? No, I didn't. I did a breakdown of his hierarchy mobile. Well, that is good.
him a sales form to sign but first he has to put it in the inbox. He can't hand it to Dwight. No. He has to put it in the inbox then Dwight signs it then Dwight puts it in the outbox where then Jim can pick it up and then they shake but Jim does not let go of his hand. And then this goes into one of those classic great fakie talking heads where you think it's just Dwight but we reveal the sidekick and it's Jim sitting just behind him. Angela did you do a breakdown of Dwight's office decor? No, I didn't. I did a breakdown of his hierarchy mobile. Well, that is good.|||他一份销售表格签字，但首先他必须把它放进收件箱。他不能直接递给德怀特。不。他必须把它放进收件箱，然后德怀特签字，接着德怀特把它放进发件箱，吉姆才能从那里拿起来，然后他们握手，但吉姆就是不松手。接着镜头切到了那种经典又棒的“假独白”——你以为只有德怀特一个人，但镜头一转，露出了坐在他身后的吉姆。安吉拉，你对德怀特的办公室装饰做过盘点吗？不，我没有。我盘点了他办公桌上的层级移动挂饰。好吧，那也不错。
I did a breakdown of it. Well, I know everything on the hierarchy mobile table. All right, well, when we get to that, I will give that over to you. Let's hear it. Here's what I spotted. Multiple old-timey photos on his desk, on his credenza, the hierarchy mobile, a photo of a jet. Yes, I saw that too.
I did a breakdown of it. Well, I know everything on the hierarchy mobile table. All right, well, when we get to that, I will give that over to you. Let's hear it. Here's what I spotted. Multiple old-timey photos on his desk, on his credenza, the hierarchy mobile, a photo of a jet. Yes, I saw that too.|||我做过盘点。好吧，那个层级移动挂饰桌上的每一样东西我都一清二楚。好吧，等我们聊到那儿时，我就交给你来讲。说来听听。我发现了这些：他的桌子上、餐边柜上有好几张复古老照片，还有层级移动挂饰，一张喷气式飞机的照片。是的，我也看到了。
I zoomed in. I got the details on that. It is the IKHA-NA. It is an unmanned aircraft that is designed for high altitude long endurance science flights. And it was actually used in a joint project of NASA and the US Forest Service and was flown in to monitor forest fires in the Western US.
I zoomed in. I got the details on that. It is the IKHA-NA. It is an unmanned aircraft that is designed for high altitude long endurance science flights. And it was actually used in a joint project of NASA and the US Forest Service and was flown in to monitor forest fires in the Western US.|||我放大看过了。我查到了它的详细信息。那是伊卡纳（IKHA-NA）号。它是一种无人驾驶飞机，专为高空长航时科学飞行而设计。它实际上曾被用于美国宇航局（NASA）和美国林务局的一个联合项目，飞往美国西部监测森林火灾。
Huh. Mm-hmm. That's very specific. Very specific that he loves that particular aircraft so much. He has a giant picture of it on his wall. I also spotted some binoculars, a boar's head, and an award of merit from March 2002 from the Greater Scranton Agrarians for Outstanding Service to the Farming Community. What was on his desk?
Huh. Mm-hmm. That's very specific. Very specific that he loves that particular aircraft so much. He has a giant picture of it on his wall. I also spotted some binoculars, a boar's head, and an award of merit from March 2002 from the Greater Scranton Agrarians for Outstanding Service to the Farming Community. What was on his desk?|||哈。嗯。真够具体的。他对那架特定的飞机爱得深沉，这也太具体了。他墙上挂着一张巨大的照片。我还发现了双筒望远镜、一个野猪头标本，以及一张2002年3月由大斯克兰顿农业协会颁发的杰出农业社区服务奖状。他的桌上有什么？
Old timey photos. No, okay, next week we're going to break down what's on his desk. His desk is very efficient. He doesn't have a bunch of crap on his desk like everybody else. That's fine. We're still going to break it down. He has the inbox and the outbox that you mentioned and some old timey photos and the end. That's it?
Old timey photos. No, okay, next week we're going to break down what's on his desk. His desk is very efficient. He doesn't have a bunch of crap on his desk like everybody other else. That's fine. We're still going to break it down. He has the inbox and the outbox that you mentioned and some old timey photos and the end. That's it?|||复古老照片。不，好吧，下周我们要盘点他桌上有什么。他的桌子非常高效。不像其他人那样桌上堆满了垃圾。没关系。我们还是要盘点一下。他有你提到的收件箱和发件箱，还有一些复古老照片，没了。就这？
Yeah, it's not a lot. No magic eight ball. No magic eight ball, but there is a kind of what looks like a type of eight ball on his credenza. Listen. Not on his desk. I got you covered. You got the credenza?
Yeah, it's not a lot. No magic eight ball. No magic eight ball, but there is a kind of what looks like a type of eight ball on his credenza. Listen. Not on his desk. I got you covered. You got the credenza?|||对，东西不多。没有神奇八号球。没有神奇八号球，但在他的餐边柜上有一个类似八号球的东西。听着。不在桌上。这部分交给我。你盘点了餐边柜？
Yes, because I zoomed in like crazy on that hierarchy mobile. So on the credenza, there is a gold frame with two old timey oval pictures of some old timey relatives. In front of it, at first I'm like, that's a magic eight ball. Yeah. No, it's not. What is it?
Yes, because I zoomed in like crazy on that hierarchy mobile. So on the credenza, there is a gold frame with two old timey oval pictures of some old timey relatives. In front of it, at first I'm like, that's a magic eight ball. Yeah. No, it's not. What is it?|||对，因为我对那个层级移动挂饰进行了疯狂放大。所以在餐边柜上，有一个金色相框，里面装着两张复古的椭圆形老亲戚照片。在它前面，一开始我想，那是神奇八号球。对。不，不是。那是什么？
I zoomed in on it, it's a globe. Oh. Yeah, it's like. Of the earth? Yeah, it's like black, but then the continents are green. Oh, okay. And then I did a breakdown of the hierarchy mobile. Let's hear it.
I zoomed in on it, it's a globe. Oh. Yeah, it's like. Of the earth? Yeah, it's like black, but then the continents are green. Oh, okay. And then I did a breakdown of the hierarchy mobile. Let's hear it.|||我放大一看，是个地球仪。哦。对，就像是。地球的？对，它是黑色的，然后大陆是绿色的。哦，好吧。然后我盘点了那个层级移动挂饰。说来听听。
Okay. I feel like this is the energy we bring to our mom detective stuff. You're like, did you do that? I'm like, no. I know. Did you do that? Ah, sort of.
Okay. I feel like this is the energy we bring to our mom detective stuff. You're like, did you do that? I'm like, no. I know. Did you do that? Ah, sort of.|||好吧。我觉得这就是我们搞“妈妈侦探”那一套时的劲头。你会说：“你做了这个吗？”我说：“没有。”我知道。你做了吗？啊，算是吧。
Okay. Here we go. Now, if you want to go to 10 minutes, you get a really good view of this, okay? Oh yeah, they're gonna talk about it. They're gonna talk about it later, but we'll share what's on it now. It is a hierarchy mobile.
Okay. Here we go. Now, if you want to go to 10 minutes, you get a really good view of this, okay? Oh yeah, they're gonna talk about it. They're gonna talk about it later, but we'll share what's on it now. It is a hierarchy mobile.|||好。我们开始吧。如果你把进度条拉到10分钟左右，你能看得很清楚，好吗？哦对，他们会聊到这个的。他们等会儿会聊到，但我们现在就来分享上面都有什么。它是一个层级移动挂饰。
You have the center, and then you have two arms that go off of it, right? So down the center, you have Dwight K. Schroot, regional manager. Then you have Jim Halpert, assistant to the regional manager and salesman, Nellie Bertram, director of special projects, Angela Martin, head accountant, Oscar Martinez, accountant, Head Accountant, Oscar Martinez, Accountant,
You have the center, and then you have two arms that go off of it, right? So down the center, you have Dwight K. Schroot, regional manager. Then you have Jim Halpert, assistant to the regional manager and salesman, Nellie Bertram, director of special projects, Angela Martin, head accountant, Oscar Martinez, accountant, Head Accountant, Oscar Martinez, Accountant,|||中间是核心，然后有两条伸出去的分支，对吧？所以在中间这一列，有：区域经理 德怀特·K·施鲁特。然后是：区域经理助理兼销售员 吉姆·哈尔珀特、特殊项目总监 内莉·伯特拉姆、首席会计师 安吉拉·马丁、会计师 奥斯卡·马丁内斯，首席会计师 奥斯卡·马丁内斯，会计师，
Kevin Malone, Accountant. To the left of the arm you have under Dwight and Jim, Toby Flinderson, Human Resources, Pam Halpert, Office Administrator, Meredith Palmer, Supplier Relations, Pete Miller, Customer Service Rep, Aaron Hannon, Receptionist. And then to the right under Dwight and Jim, it has Darrell Philbin, head of shipping and distribution. Stanley Hudson, salesman. Phyllis Vance, salesman. Clark Green, junior salesman. Did we know Clark's last name? I don't think we did.
Kevin Malone, Accountant. To the left of the arm you have under Dwight and Jim, Toby Flinderson, Human Resources, Pam Halpert, Office Administrator, Meredith Palmer, Supplier Relations, Pete Miller, Customer Service Rep, Aaron Hannon, Receptionist. And then to the right under Dwight and Jim, it has Darrell Philbin, head of shipping and distribution. Stanley Hudson, salesman. Phyllis Vance, salesman. Clark Green, junior salesman. Did we know Clark's last name? I don't think we did.|||会计师 凯文·马隆。在左侧分支上，位于德怀特和吉姆之下的是：人力资源 托比·弗林德森、办公室行政 帕姆·哈尔珀特、供应商关系 梅雷迪思·帕尔默、客户服务代表 皮特·米勒、前台 艾伦·汉农。然后在右侧，位于德怀特和吉姆之下的是：运输与配送主管 达雷尔·菲尔宾、销售员 斯坦利·哈德森、销售员 菲利斯·万斯、初级销售员 克拉克·格林。我们之前知道克拉克的姓氏吗？我觉得我们不知道。
Now we do. He is Clark Green. And then Creed Bratton, quality assurance. Wow. Yeah, and I thought Phyllis might have been Phyllis Lapinvance, but she only has one last name listed. Oh, OK. There you go.
Now we do. He is Clark Green. And then Creed Bratton, quality assurance. Wow. Yeah, and I thought Phyllis might have been Phyllis Lapinvance, but she only has one last name listed. Oh, OK. There you go.|||现在知道了。他是克拉克·格林。然后是质检 柯里德·布拉顿。哇。对，我以前以为菲利斯可能是菲利斯·拉皮·万斯，但上面只列了一个姓氏。哦，好吧。就是这样。
Clark Green, everybody. And I think we now have the official word on what Creed does as well. Quality Assurance. Yeah. Also, I didn't realize that Meredith was supplier relations. You know what?
Clark Green, everybody. And I think we now have the official word on what Creed does as well. Quality Assurance. Yeah. Also, I didn't realize that Meredith was supplier relations. You know what?|||大家注意，克拉克·格林。我想我们现在也得到了关于柯里德具体职务的官方说法：质检。对。还有，我之前没意识到梅雷迪思负责供应商关系。你知道吗？
Maybe we did know that, because isn't that why she was sleeping with people? Yes. Yes. Yes. We did know that. Keeping was supplier relations. You know what? Maybe we did know that because isn't that why she was sleeping with people? Yes, yes, yes. We didn't know that. That's right. OK. Well, before we leave this office, I've got one more fan question. It's from Alexis P and Marietto, Ohio, who said, there is a portrait of Dwight and Mo's in the background behind Jim inside
Maybe we did know that, because isn't that why she was sleeping with people? Yes. Yes. Yes. We did know that. Keeping was supplier relations. You know what? Maybe we did know that because isn't that why she was sleeping with people? Yes, yes, yes. We didn't know that. That's right. OK. Well, before we leave this office, I've got one more fan question. It's from Alexis P and Marietto, Ohio, who said, there is a portrait of Dwight and Mo's in the background behind Jim inside|||也许我们其实知道，因为这不就是她跟别人睡觉的原因吗？是的。是的。是的。我们其实知道。负责供应商关系。你知道吗？也许我们其实知道，因为这不就是她跟别人睡觉的原因吗？是的，是的，是的。我们其实知道。没错。好吧。在离开这个办公室之前，我还有一个粉丝提问。来自俄亥俄州马里埃塔的亚历克西斯·P，他说，在吉姆身后、德怀特办公室内部的背景里，有一幅德怀特和莫斯的肖像画。
Dwight's office. Did Rain and Mike Schur have to sit for a portrait together? Also, who was the artist? Please tell us everything. Well, this painting has been established before. It was in the farm. That's right, Angela. Yes, I did not remember that.
Dwight's office. Did Rain and Mike Schur have to sit for a portrait together? Also, who was the artist? Please tell us everything. Well, this painting has been established before. It was in the farm. That's right, Angela. Yes, I did not remember that.|||雷恩和迈克·舒尔必须一起坐着当模特来画这幅画吗？还有，艺术家是谁？请把一切都告诉我们吧。好吧，这幅画之前就已经出场过了。它在农场里出现过。没错，安吉拉。是的，我不记得了。
But Dave Rogers pointed that out to me. Steve Burgess said that it was painted by Jules Kometsko, who Filchay had make pretty much all of our office art. She did Pam's watercolor, for example. She did this portrait. She did the one that you're gonna see in the conference room soon, and nobody had to sit for these portraits. She worked off of photographs.
But Dave Rogers pointed that out to me. Steve Burgess said that it was painted by Jules Kometsko, who Filchay had make pretty much all of our office art. She did Pam's watercolor, for example. She did this portrait. She did the one that you're gonna see in the conference room soon, and nobody had to sit for these portraits. She worked off of photographs.|||但戴夫·罗杰斯向我指出了这一点。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，这幅画是由朱尔斯·科梅茨科绘制的，菲尔奇（指道具组）几乎让我们办公室所有的艺术品都出自她手。比如，她画了帕姆的水彩画。她画了这幅肖像。她还画了你们很快就会在会议室里看到的那幅画，而且没有人需要为这些肖像去当模特。她是根据照片画的。
Cassie, will you put her on our list for Office Lady 6.0? I'd love to hear about all the different artwork on the set of the office and what she created and just hear all about it. That's a good idea. Our list for Office Ladies 6.0 is really getting long. We realize there's a lot of stuff to still talk about. Yeah. Listen, I know it's a little early but I might need to take a break. I want to refill my pockets mug. I want to use the restroom.
Cassie, will you put her on our list for Office Lady 6.0? I'd love to hear about all the different artwork on the set of the office and what she created and just hear all about it. That's a good idea. Our list for Office Ladies 6.0 is really getting long. We realize there's a lot of stuff to still talk about. Yeah. Listen, I know it's a little early but I might need to take a break. I want to refill my pockets mug. I want to use the restroom.|||卡茜，你能把她加入我们的《办公室女士》6.0季待办清单吗？我很想了解《办公室》片场的各种艺术品以及她创作的作品，听听关于这一切的故事。是个好主意。我们《办公室女士》6.0季的清单真的越来越长了。我们发现还有很多事情要聊。对。听着，我知道现在还有点早，但我可能需要休息一下。我想给我的口袋马克杯重新倒满水。我想去趟洗手间。
I want to eat a cheese stick. Is that all right? I am never, ever going to stop you from eating cheese. All right. Ever. Thank you. Well, we're going to take a break and we'll be right back. We have had snacks.
I want to eat a cheese stick. Is that all right? I am never, ever going to stop you from eating cheese. All right. Ever. Thank you. Well, we're going to take a break and we'll be right back. We have had snacks.|||我想吃一根奶酪棒。行吗？我永远、永远都不会阻止你吃奶酪的。好吧。永远不会。谢谢。好了，我们要休息一下，马上回来。我们已经吃过零食了。
And we're ready to talk about the fact that Jim and Dwight run a no-nonsense office. It's been six days since their last nonsense. That's right. Jim holds up a chalkboard that says five days, and Dwight erases it and writes in the number six. They're very serious about the no nonsense. Now Jim is going to join Pam at their desk clump, and he's going to say the pre-conference room
And we're ready to talk about the fact that Jim and Dwight run a no-nonsense office. It's been six days since their last nonsense. That's right. Jim holds up a chalkboard that says five days, and Dwight erases it and writes in the number six. They're very serious about the no nonsense. Now Jim is going to join Pam at their desk clump, and he's going to say the pre-conference room|||我们准备聊聊吉姆和德怀特如何管理一个“绝不容忍胡闹”的办公室。距离他们上一次胡闹已经过去六天了。没错。吉姆举起一块写着“五天”的小黑板，德怀特擦掉它，写上了数字六。他们对“不容胡闹”这件事非常认真。现在吉姆要回到帕姆身边的办公桌区，他说会前
meeting went well, which bodes well for the post-conference room meeting. Ultimately, it all does depend on the conference room meeting itself. And then he gets a call, and it's from the folks at Athlead. They're wondering, you know, what's up with him? Is he coming back? What's going on?
meeting went well, which bodes well for the post-conference room meeting. Ultimately, it all does depend on the conference room meeting itself. And then he gets a call, and it's from the folks at Athlead. They're wondering, you know, what's up with him? Is he coming back? What's going on?|||会议开得很顺利，这预示着会后会议也会很顺利。归根结底，一切还是要看会议本身。然后他接到了一个电话，是“巅峰领跑”（Athlead）的人打来的。他们想知道，你知道的，他最近怎么样？他要回来吗？怎么回事？
Is he going to go on this three month tour? 32 cities or something like that? Yeah, they really want him to go. Jim is going to share a little bit more about this in a talking head. He said, I guess they would be meeting athletes on their own turf, building relationships. It sounds really fun. But he said no, and that's final because he doesn't want to risk losing Pam again over athlete. And then Pam has a talking head where she feels relieved, but also a little guilty. She kind of feels like he's giving up this big thing for her, but he seems happy. You know, he's been goofing around a lot and she really loves goofy Jim. Here's what I want to say to that. Oh, I've got my mug in my hand. Okay. Well,
Is he going to go on this three month tour? 32 cities or something like that? Yeah, they really want him to go. Jim is going to share a little bit more about this in a talking head. He said, I guess they would be meeting athletes on their own turf, building relationships. It sounds really fun. But he said no, and that's final because he doesn't want to risk losing Pam again over athlete. And then Pam has a talking head where she feels relieved, but also a little guilty. She kind of feels like he's giving up this big thing for her, but he seems happy. You know, he's been goofing around a lot and she really loves goofy Jim. Here's what I want to say to that. Oh, I've got my mug in my hand. Okay. Well,|||他要参加这次为期三个月的巡回演出吗？去32个城市还是什么的？对，他们真的很希望他去。吉姆在独白中分享了更多这方面的信息。他说，我想他们会在运动员自己的地盘上与他们会面，建立联系。听起来真的很有趣。但他拒绝了，而且心意已决，因为他不想为了“巅峰领跑”冒再次失去帕姆的风险。然后帕姆有一段独白，她感到松了一口气，但也有一点负罪感。她觉得他为了自己放弃了这么大的一件事，但他看起来挺快乐的。你知道的，他一直在瞎胡闹，而她真的很爱那个傻里傻气的吉姆。对此我想说的是。哦，我手里拿着杯子呢。好吧。好吧，
my mug doesn't have pockets, but has a hummingbird that's ready to buzz around. All right, you start. Um, grow up. I spit off my coffee. Go on. That's what I want to say to Pam. Grow up. And Jim, you're adults. You have family. You have a home. Goofy Jim was in his twenties. They're older now and the two of them need to evolve as a couple at the workplace and with their goals and goofy Jim it just pissed me off. Okay. Okay. How was that? That was good and it was not my soapbox. Okay. So here's what I have to say. It's not that Jim almost lost Pam because he went to athlete. Jim almost lost Pam because he was dishonest and sneaky and non-communicative and made decisions without her input.
my mug doesn't have pockets, but has a hummingbird that's ready to buzz around. All right, you start. Um, grow up. I spit off my coffee. Go on. That's what I want to say to Pam. Grow up. And Jim, you're adults. You have family. You have a home. Goofy Jim was in his twenties. They're older now and the two of them need to evolve as a couple at the workplace and with their goals and goofy Jim it just pissed me off. Okay. Okay. How was that? That was good and it was not my soapbox. Okay. So here's what I have to say. It's not that Jim almost lost Pam because he went to athlete. Jim almost lost Pam because he was dishonest and sneaky and non-communicative and made decisions without her input.|||我的杯子没有口袋，但上面有一只随时准备嗡嗡盘旋蜂鸣的蜂鸟。好吧，你先说。嗯，成熟点吧。我差点把咖啡喷出来。继续。这就是我想对帕姆说的话。成熟点吧。还有吉姆，你们是成年人了。你们有家庭。你们有家。傻里傻气的吉姆那是二十多岁的时候。他们现在年纪大了，他们俩需要在职场上以及在人生目标上作为一个伴侣共同成长，而那个傻里傻气的吉姆真的气死我了。好吧。好吧。刚才那段怎么样？挺好的，而且这可不是我的长篇大论。好吧。所以我要说的是：并不是因为吉姆去了“巅峰领跑”才差点失去帕姆。吉姆差点失去帕姆，是因为他不诚实、鬼鬼祟祟、缺乏沟通，并且在没有她参与的情况下做出了决定。
And now all they've done is swing too far in the opposite direction. What this couple needs is to communicate. And grow up. Yes, exactly. Jim is allowed to start a business, and Pam is allowed to feel overwhelmed and lonely. And there is a way that they could do this all if they would just talk to each other more. That's right.
And now all they've done is swing too far in the opposite direction. What this couple needs is to communicate. And grow up. Yes, exactly. Jim is allowed to start a business, and Pam is allowed to feel overwhelmed and lonely. And there is a way that they could do this all if they would just talk to each other more. That's right.|||而现在他们所做的，只是走向了另一个极端。这对夫妻需要的是沟通。然后成熟起来。是的，完全正确。吉姆可以创业，帕姆也可以感到不知所措和孤独。只要他们多跟彼此沟通，他们完全可以找到两全其美的办法。没错。
It's not solved by just making this giant new decision to just come back and be goofy Jim. Clearly they are on my last nerve. Yeah. Equally, the two of them. The two of them. But also Pam is really on my last nerve. She's gonna get on my major last nerve
It's not solved by just making this giant new decision to just come back and be goofy Jim. Clearly they are on my last nerve. Yeah. Equally, the two of them. The two of them. But also Pam is really on my last nerve. She's gonna get on my major last nerve|||这个问题不是靠做一个重大的新决定——直接回来当那个傻里傻气的吉姆——就能解决的。显然他们俩都把我惹毛了。对。两人都一样。他们俩。不过帕姆也确实快把我惹毛了。她等会儿会更彻底地
a little later in this episode. Okay. Right now it's both of them. All right. Nana put your tissue back in your pocket. I know. All right. All right. It felt good to get that off my chest. Well good. We are now going to have a conference room meeting and we learned Dwight begins every meeting with an inspirational quote. He's made himself a fast fact. Right now it probably seems fun,
a little later in this episode. Okay. Right now it's both of them. All right. Nana put your tissue back in your pocket. I know. All right. All right. It felt good to get that off my chest. Well good. We are now going to have a conference room meeting and we learned Dwight begins every meeting with an inspirational quote. He's made himself a fast fact. Right now it probably seems fun,|||把我惹毛的。好吧。现在他们俩半斤八两。好吧。纳娜，把纸巾放回口袋里吧。我知道。好吧。好吧。把心里话说出来感觉好多了。很好。接下来我们要开个会议，我们了解到德怀特每次开会都以一句励志名言开场。他给自己做了一个快讯小常识。现在看起来可能挺好玩的，
but several meetings in he's gonna be like, God damn, I gotta come up with a stupid inspirational quote. He's gonna make Jim do it. Yeah, but then Jim will pass it on to his other assistant so he'll be doing it for himself. Here's the quote, some say the only failure there is, is the failure to try. And then he rings a buzzer, eh, that is wrong.
but several meetings in he's gonna be like, God damn, I gotta come up with a stupid inspirational quote. He's gonna make Jim do it. Yeah, but then Jim will pass it on to his other assistant so he'll be doing it for himself. Here's the quote, some say the only failure there is, is the failure to try. And then he rings a buzzer, eh, that is wrong.|||但开会开多了他就会想：妈的，我得想个蠢透了的励志名言。他会逼吉姆去想。对，但吉姆会把它转交给他的另一个助理，所以最后还是他自己在干这事。名言是这样的：“有人说，唯一的失败就是不敢尝试。”然后他按了一下蜂鸣器：呃，错。
Failure of any kind is failure. Jim, over to you. Now Jim is gonna remind everyone of their no nonsense rule. Pam's gonna raise her hand and present a scenario to clarify whether or not this is nonsense or not. Now we have goofy Jim and Pam. Pam's example is if someone came in
Failure of any kind is failure. Jim, over to you. Now Jim is gonna remind everyone of their no nonsense rule. Pam's gonna raise her hand and present a scenario to clarify whether or not this is nonsense or not. Now we have goofy Jim and Pam. Pam's example is if someone came in|||任何形式的失败都是失败。吉姆，交给你了。现在吉姆要提醒大家他们的“不容胡闹”规则。帕姆举手提出了一个情景，以澄清这到底算不算胡闹。现在我们迎来了傻里傻气的吉姆和帕姆。帕姆举的例子是：如果有人进来
and they were carrying water jugs, could you say nice jugs? I was very surprised by Pam's example. Pam's example sounds like something Todd Packer would pitch. Well, interestingly enough, this was a candy bag joke. This was not the originally scripted joke. Interesting.
and they were carrying water jugs, could you say nice jugs? I was very surprised by Pam's example. Pam's example sounds like something Todd Packer would pitch. Well, interestingly enough, this was a candy bag joke. This was not the originally scripted joke. Interesting.|||手里搬着饮水机水桶，你能说句“好大的水桶（亦有双关义）”吗？我被帕姆举的例子惊到了。帕姆举的例子听起来像是托德·帕克尔会出的主意。嗯，有趣的是，这是一个“糖果袋”笑话（即备选笑话）。这不是剧本原本写的笑话。有趣。
Well, Jim says that's obviously nonsense. And what percentage of nonsense do we tolerate in this office? And everyone replies zero. No nonsense. You can't have any nonsense. Now Angela's gonna arrive. She's just gotten to work. She's a little late. And she's carrying Philip. Yes, we did film a whole scene that got cut out where Angela takes Philip to daycare and they turn her away because of the Senator scandal and Oscar. There is a blooper from that scene. It's on the DVD extras because the little boy playing Philip really wanted to like run. There was like grass and like stuff and I'm holding him and he wanted down and so I'm
Well, Jim says that's obviously nonsense. And what percentage of nonsense do we tolerate in this office? And everyone replies zero. No nonsense. You can't have any nonsense. Now Angela's gonna arrive. She's just gotten to work. She's a little late. And she's carrying Philip. Yes, we did film a whole scene that got cut out where Angela takes Philip to daycare and they turn her away because of the Senator scandal and Oscar. There is a blooper from that scene. It's on the DVD extras because the little boy playing Philip really wanted to like run. There was like grass and like stuff and I'm holding him and he wanted down and so I'm|||好吧，吉姆说这显然是胡闹。我们在办公室里容忍百分之多少的胡闹？每个人都回答：零。绝不胡闹。一点胡闹都不能有。现在安吉拉到了。她刚上班。她迟到了一会儿。她抱着菲利普。是的，我们确实拍了一整场被删掉的戏：安吉拉带着菲利普去日托中心，但因为参议员的丑闻和奥斯卡，他们拒绝接收。那场戏有个NG花絮。它在DVD花絮里，因为扮演菲利普的小男孩真的很想跑。外面有草地什么的，我抱着他，他却想下来，所以我就
like trying to say my line and juggle him and I just get so tickled. He wins. He gets down. I let him down. Well it's interesting you mentioned him because we got a fan question from Jesse in Edmonton who said, is the actor that plays Philip related to Rain in any way? Because they really look so alike and if not, hats off to the casting team. Well baby Philip was played by twins Vince and Evan Edwards, this was their first on-camera gig on a professional set. They were so cute and they were just so sweet. You know we've shared we would go and spend time with any kids that played our children just to get to know them and I just remember them being so stinkin' cute.
like trying to say my line and juggle him and I just get so tickled. He wins. He gets down. I let him down. Well it's interesting you mentioned him because we got a fan question from Jesse in Edmonton who said, is the actor that plays Philip related to Rain in any way? Because they really look so alike and if not, hats off to the casting team. Well baby Philip was played by twins Vince and Evan Edwards, this was their first on-camera gig on a professional set. They were so cute and they were just so sweet. You know we've shared we would go and spend time with any kids that played our children just to get to know them and I just remember them being so stinkin' cute.|||一边试着念台词一边手忙脚乱地抱住他，我逗得直笑。他赢了。他要下来。我把他放了下来。你提到他这很有意思，因为我们收到了埃德蒙顿的杰西发来的一位粉丝提问，他说：扮演菲利普的演员跟雷恩有什么亲戚关系吗？因为他们真的长得太像了，如果没有的话，向选角团队致敬。扮演婴儿菲利普的是一对双胞胎文斯和埃文·爱德华兹，这是他们第一次在专业片场面对镜头演出。他们太可爱了，简直甜得不行。你知道的，我们分享过，我们会花时间陪任何扮演我们孩子的孩子们，以便更好地了解他们，我只记得他们可爱得要命。
They were so cute. And they were also not related to anyone on the set. I asked Dave, what were the casting requirements to find this baby, Phillip? Uh-oh. Well, he said they did not actively search for babies that would look like Dwight or look like Angela. That was just luck.
They were so cute. And they were also not related to anyone on the set. I asked Dave, what were the casting requirements to find this baby, Phillip? Uh-oh. Well, he said they did not actively search for babies that would look like Dwight or look like Angela. That was just luck.|||他们太可爱了。而且他们和片场的任何人都没有血缘关系。我问戴夫，寻找这个婴儿菲利普的选角要求是什么？噢。好吧，他说他们并没有刻意寻找长得像德怀特或长得像安吉拉的婴儿。那纯粹是运气。
He said their main search criteria was, could they do all the actions required? Because they actually have a lot that they need to do. And it's really challenging for babies to be on set with a lot of strange people, you know? And that after a meeting with several sets of twins, Evan and Vincent came in, and Dave said he instantly knew this was the new baby Shroot.
He said their main search criteria was, could they do all the actions required? Because they actually have a lot that they need to do. And it's really challenging for babies to be on set with a lot of strange people, you know? And that after a meeting with several sets of twins, Evan and Vincent came in, and Dave said he instantly knew this was the new baby Shroot.|||他说他们主要的搜寻标准是：他们能完成所有要求的动作吗？因为他们实际上有很多事情需要做。对于婴儿来说，在有很多陌生人的片场拍戏真的极具挑战性，你知道的？在见过好几对双胞胎后，埃文和文森特来了，戴夫说他一眼就知道这就是施鲁特家的“新宝宝”。
He said they were just really calm, very attentive, and they were really cool with being held by both you and Rain. Yeah, and Oscar. And you know, you'll see me in the conference room. I have a little toy that was his actual toy, you know. So we did have things even on set that were actually his to make him feel more at home. Well anyway that's how we found them and Dave did say he was absolutely delighted that they did sort of look a little bit like Rainn and
He said they were just really calm, very attentive, and they were really cool with being held by both you and Rain. Yeah, and Oscar. And you know, you'll see me in the conference room. I have a little toy that was his actual toy, you know. So we did have things even on set that were actually his to make him feel more at home. Well anyway that's how we found them and Dave did say he was absolutely delighted that they did sort of look a little bit like Rainn and|||他说他们非常冷静、极其专心，而且对你和雷恩抱他们都表现得非常淡定。对，还有奥斯卡。你知道的，你在会议室里会看到我。我有一个小玩具，那是他真正的玩具，你知道的。所以我们在片场甚至有一些真正属于他的东西，好让他觉得更自在一些。总之，我们就是这样找到他们的，戴夫确实说过，他感到非常高兴的是，他们确实长得有点像雷恩，
they had your blonde hair. He said it was amazing. It was really good casting. Dwight is gonna say Philip can stay and he announces that he's gonna let everyone off half an hour early so they can go watch the documentary. But you have to make up the time. You know, he said you can make it up by either staying 30 minutes later tomorrow or one minute for the rest of the month. Yeah, what would you do?
they had your blonde hair. He said it was amazing. It was really good casting. Dwight is gonna say Philip can stay and he announces that he's gonna let everyone off half an hour early so they can go watch the documentary. But you have to make up the time. You know, he said you can make it up by either staying 30 minutes later tomorrow or one minute for the rest of the month. Yeah, what would you do?|||而且有着你那样的金发。他说这太神奇了。这选角真是绝了。德怀特说菲利普可以留下，并宣布他要让大家提前半小时下班，这样他们就可以去看纪录片了。但你必须把时间补回来。你知道的，他说你可以通过明天多留30分钟，或者在这个月的剩余时间里每天多留一分钟来补上。对，换作你会怎么做？
Would you stay 30 minutes or one extra minute? I would stay 30 minutes. I would stay 30 minutes and get it done. But also like, what am I gonna do with one extra minute a day? Unless I run one minute late usually. Then it doesn't change my day much. It doesn't.
Would you stay 30 minutes or one extra minute? I would stay 30 minutes. I would stay 30 minutes and get it done. But also like, what am I gonna do with one extra minute a day? Unless I run one minute late usually. Then it doesn't change my day much. It doesn't.|||你会选择多留30分钟还是一天多留一分钟？我会留30分钟。我会留30分钟一次性搞定。但话说回来，一天多出一分钟我能干嘛呢？除非我平时经常迟到一分钟。那倒对我的生活没什么太大影响。确实没有。
Well, now we're going to see some talking heads from people. And we're getting some insights into how people feel about the fact that this documentary is going to be airing starting tonight. Meredith is like, I better come out smelling like a rose. I've been on my best behavior for nine years. If it wasn't for the cameras, I would have done some truly vulgar crap. Noted. Stanley notes that over the course of the documentary, he's had three affairs. And if you find his body in a ditch, let me save the police some trouble. My wife did it. Yeah. Kevin announces that he's going to be watching the
Well, now we're going to see some talking heads from people. And we're getting some insights into how people feel about the fact that this documentary is going to be airing starting tonight. Meredith is like, I better come out smelling like a rose. I've been on my best behavior for nine years. If it wasn't for the cameras, I would have done some truly vulgar crap. Noted. Stanley notes that over the course of the documentary, he's had three affairs. And if you find his body in a ditch, let me save the police some trouble. My wife did it. Yeah. Kevin announces that he's going to be watching the|||好了，接下来我们要看一些大家的独白。我们能借此一窥大家对于这部纪录片从今晚开始播出的真实感受。梅雷迪思觉得：我最好能全身而退、保持清白。我这九年来表现得无可挑剔。要不是有摄像机在拍，我早就干出一些极其粗俗的烂事了。记下了。斯坦利指出，在纪录片拍摄期间，他有过三次外遇。如果你在水沟里发现他的尸体，就当是帮警察省点麻烦吧：是我老婆干的。对。凯文宣布他将在
documentary at Poor Richards and that everyone is welcome. Well, why is he watching it at Poor Richards? Well, it has something to do with an all you can eat shrimp commercial. He charged the TV. Yeah. When the shrimp commercial came on, and he broke his TV. You know, my friend Luda, who I was out here with in my very earliest of days, she went to college with me.
documentary at Poor Richards and that everyone is welcome. Well, why is he watching it at Poor Richards? Well, it has something to do with an all you can eat shrimp commercial. He charged the TV. Yeah. When the shrimp commercial came on, and he broke his TV. You know, my friend Luda, who I was out here with in my very earliest of days, she went to college with me.|||“可怜理查德”酒吧观看纪录片，欢迎所有人前往。那他为什么要去“可怜理查德”看呢？哦，这跟一个虾肉无限量畅吃的广告有关。他把电视砸了。对。当那个虾的广告播出来时，他把自己的电视给砸了。你知道的，我的朋友露达，我刚来洛杉矶闯荡时最早认识的朋友之一，她跟我一起上大学。
We both came out to LA to be actresses. She was in a Red Lobster all you can eat shrimp commercial. No way. What was her part? She said she had a line. She had a line. That's huge. I know she had a line. That's huge. I know. She had a line. And then there was something about it where she got to eat
We both came out to LA to be actresses. She was in a Red Lobster all you can eat shrimp commercial. No way. What was her part? She said she had a line. She had a line. That's huge. I know she had a line. That's huge. I know. She had a line. And then there was something about it where she got to eat|||我们俩一起来到洛杉矶当演员。她拍过一个红 lobster（红龙虾餐厅）虾肉无限量畅吃的广告。不会吧。她演的什么角色？她说她有台词。她有台词。太厉害了。我知道她有台词。太厉害了。我知道。她有台词。然后因此她还
at Red Lobster for free for a while. We ate so much Red Lobster because she had done this commercial. I mean, it was so many of those cheddar biscuits that are so good. But I mean, she got us through that commercial and that free red lobster. It got us through some lean times in our early actor days. I bet. I did the Lay's Wow potato chip commercial and I had to eat them. You know, the one that had
at Red Lobster for free for a while. We ate so much Red Lobster because she had done this commercial. I mean, it was so many of those cheddar biscuits that are so good. But I mean, she got us through that commercial and that free red lobster. It got us through some lean times in our early actor days. I bet. I did the Lay's Wow potato chip commercial and I had to eat them. You know, the one that had|||有一阵子能在红龙虾免费吃霸王餐。我们吃了超级多红龙虾，就因为她拍了这个广告。我是说，吃了那么多那么好吃的切达干酪饼。不过我是说，她靠着那个广告和免费的红龙虾，让我们度过了早年当演员时的一段艰难时期。我信。我拍过乐事“Wow”无脂薯片广告，我得一直吃。你知道的，就是那种含有
a Lester that caused anal leakage. Yeah. I had to eat those chips all day. I take a bite and I'd say, wow, that was my only line. I was fine, did not mess up my constitution at all. Oh, so anyway, I didn't get free shrimp, but I did get some potato chips. You also didn't get anal leakage, which I think is good. It's a bonus. Yeah.
a Lester that calories... caused anal leakage. Yeah. I had to eat those chips all day. I take a bite and I'd say, wow, that was my only line. I was fine, did not mess up my constitution at all. Oh, so anyway, I didn't get free shrimp, but I did get some potato chips. You also didn't get anal leakage, which I think is good. It's a bonus. Yeah.|||老斯特（注：口误，指奧利司他/Olean）会引发肛门漏油的那个。对。我得一整天都在吃那些薯片。我咬一口然后说：“哇哦”——那是我的唯一一句台词。我没事，完全没有搞垮我的肠胃。哦，总之，我没吃到免费的虾，但我确实吃到了一些薯片。你也没得肛门漏油，我觉得这挺好的。算是个额外收获吧。对。
I think they discontinued those though, right? I think they did, and Red Lobster went out of business because of their all-you-can-eat shrimp. Oh my God, I think they discontinued those though, right? I think they did and Red Lobster went out of business because of their All You Can Eat Shrimp. Oh my god, I think that's right. Yeah. Right? I think I read that. I think I did too, that it really did them in. Well, it did Kevin's TV in. It sure did. See how it brought us back?
I think they discontinued those though, right? I think they did, and Red Lobster went out of business because of their all-you-can-eat shrimp. Oh my God, I think they discontinued those though, right? I think they did and Red Lobster went out of business because of their All You Can Eat Shrimp. Oh my god, I think that's right. Yeah. Right? I think I read that. I think I did too, that it really did them in. Well, it did Kevin's TV in. It sure did. See how it brought us back?|||不过我想他们后来停产了对吧？我想是的，而且红龙虾餐厅就是因为他们的虾肉无限量畅吃活动而倒闭的。天哪，我想他们后来停产了对吧？我想是的，而且红龙虾餐厅就是因为他们的虾肉无限量畅吃活动而倒闭的。天哪，我觉得是对的。对。是吗？我好像看过这篇报道。我也觉得是的，这活动确实把他们整垮了。好吧，它也把凯文的电视给整垮了。确实如此。看我们是怎么绕回来的？
You brought it back, lady. Now, Oscar's also going to say he can't believe that this documentary is finally airing and notes that when they started filming he was still having sex with women. As was Kevin I believe. Creed says this airs tonight. Oh man if my parents see this I am toast. Creed's parents? I want to do an episode just called Creed.
You brought it back, lady. Now, Oscar's also going to say he can't believe that this documentary is finally airing and notes that when they started filming he was still having sex with women. As was Kevin I believe. Creed says this airs tonight. Oh man if my parents see this I am toast. Creed's parents? I want to do an episode just called Creed.|||是你绕回来的，小姐。现在，奥斯卡也说他简直不敢相信这部纪录片终于要播出了，并指出当他们开始拍摄时，他还在和女性发生性关系。我相信凯文也是。柯里德说今晚就要播出了。天哪，如果我父母看到这个，我就死定了。柯里德的父母？我想做一集专门就叫《柯里德》。
Well who else wanted to do that? Was it Mike Schur or was it BJ Novak? One of the two of them told us that they wanted to follow Creed for a whole day. I'd love it. Well, now we're going to cut back to Andy. He's still waiting in line to audition. And suddenly a cute blonde is going to appear behind him. She wants some camera time.
Well who else wanted to do that? Was it Mike Schur or was it BJ Novak? One of the two of them told us that they wanted to follow Creed for a whole day. I'd love it. Well, now we're going to cut back to Andy. He's still waiting in line to audition. And suddenly a cute blonde is going to appear behind him. She wants some camera time.|||还有谁想这么干来着？是迈克·舒尔还是B·J·诺瓦克？他们俩中的一个曾告诉我们，他们想跟着柯里德整整一天。我很想看。好吧，现在镜头切回安迪。他还在排队等待试镜。突然，一个可爱的金发女郎出现在他身后。她想争取一些出镜时间。
She's Casey Dean. We don't need to tell you who she is. She's gonna tell you herself. Let's hear it. Woohoo! Casey Dean, Cincinnati, Ohio. Doctor, doctor, give me the news. I got a great Casey Dean for you.
She's Casey Dean. We don't need to tell you who she is. She's gonna tell you herself. Let's hear it. Woohoo! Casey Dean, Cincinnati, Ohio. Doctor, doctor, give me the news. I got a great Casey Dean for you.|||她是凯西·迪恩。我们不需要告诉你她是谁。她会自己告诉你。听听看。呜呼！凯西·迪恩，来自俄亥俄州辛辛那提。医生，医生，快告诉我好消息。我给你们带来了一个超棒的凯西·迪恩。
No. America! No, this is my time. Casey Dean was played by Jessica Sinclair. She is a member of Upright Citizens Brigade Improv Comedy. She is a powerhouse. She co-created and starred in USA's Playing House. She has a podcast.
No. America! No, this is my time. Casey Dean was played by Jessica Sinclair. She is a member of Upright Citizens Brigade Improv Comedy. She is a powerhouse. She co-created and starred in USA's Playing House. She has a podcast.|||不。美国！不，这是我的高光时刻。凯西·迪恩由杰西卡·圣克莱尔饰演。她是“正直公民大剧团”（Upright Citizens Brigade）即兴喜剧的成员。她是个实力派。她联合创作并主演了美国电视网（USA）的《为人父母》（Playing House）。她有一个播客。
She sure does. Called The Deep Dive with June Diane Raphael, who, as you know, is one of the women who inspired us to start our podcast. We reached out to Jessica via our old producer at Earwolf, Cody Fisher, who produced their podcast, The Deep Dive. She put us in touch. We were so excited to hear from Jessica about how she got her role in The Office, and we had a few other questions for her.
She sure does. Called The Deep Dive with June Diane Raphael, who, as you know, is one of the women who inspired us to start our podcast. We reached out to Jessica via our old producer at Earwolf, Cody Fisher, who produced their podcast, The Deep Dive. She put us in touch. We were so excited to hear from Jessica about how she got her role in The Office, and we had a few other questions for her.|||她确实有。叫做《深度挖掘》（The Deep Dive），主持人是朱恩·黛安·拉斐尔，大家知道的，她就是启发我们创办播客的女性之一。我们通过Earwolf的老制作人科迪·费舍尔联系到了杰西卡，科迪曾制作过她们的播客《深度挖掘》。她帮我们搭了线。听到杰西卡讲述她是如何得到《办公室》里的角色的，我们感到非常兴奋，我们还有几个其他问题要问她。
We're going to sprinkle those in, but let's start with how she got her role in The Office. Hi, guys. So thank you so much for asking me to even weigh in on this episode. It really was a highlight for me. I'm a huge fan of The Office. And I know the show was ending, and I thought, well, that's it for me.
We're going to sprinkle those in, but let's start with how she got her role in The Office. Hi, guys. So thank you so much for asking me to even weigh in on this episode. It really was a highlight for me. I'm a huge fan of The Office. And I know the show was ending, and I thought, well, that's it for me.|||我们会把这些穿插在节目中，但先从她是如何得到《办公室》的角色开始聊起。嗨，大家好。非常感谢邀请我来聊聊这一集。这对我来说真的是个高光时刻。我是《办公室》的超级粉丝。我知道这部剧快要完结了，当时我想，好吧，我没机会了。
You guys were going to be the one that got away and at the last minute I got a call and I really think it was like two days before the before it shot so maybe Sandra Bullock wasn't available and then they went down the list but I was so happy to do it because Ed Helms is such a dear friend of mine and an old friend from the UCB, Upright Citizens Brigade Theater in our 20s, back when I had Hugh Grant's haircut from Four Weddings and a Funeral. And so I knew I was gonna get to spend the day with Ed,
You guys were going to be the one that got away and at the last minute I got a call and I really think it was like two days before the before it shot so maybe Sandra Bullock wasn't available and then they went down the list but I was so happy to do it because Ed Helms is such a dear friend of mine and an old friend from the UCB, Upright Citizens Brigade Theater in our 20s, back when I had Hugh Grant's haircut from Four Weddings and a Funeral. And so I knew I was gonna get to spend the day with Ed,|||你们就要成为我错过的遗憾了，但在最后一分钟我接到了电话，我真的觉得大概是在开拍前两天才通知的，也许是桑德拉·布洛克没空，然后剧组才顺着候选名单往下找的，但我太高兴能出演了，因为艾德·海姆斯是我的挚友，也是我们二十多岁时在UCB（正直公民大剧团剧院）的老朋友，当时我留着《四个婚礼和一个葬礼》里休·格兰特那种发型。所以我知道我能和艾德共度一整天，
so that was amazing. I love that she compared her haircut to Hugh Grant in Four Weddings and a Funeral. I have seen that movie so many times. I have an instant image of what her hair looked like. She's so funny. So funny. And she's going to give us some more delicious nuggets as we go on.
so that amazing. I love that she compared her haircut to Hugh Grant in Four Weddings and a Funeral. I have seen that movie so many times. I have an instant image of what her hair looked like. She's so funny. So funny. And she's going to give us some more delicious nuggets as we go on.|||所以太棒了。我太喜欢她把自己的发型比作《四个婚礼和一个葬礼》里的休·格兰特了。那部电影我看了无数遍。我脑海里立刻就能浮现出她当时的发型。她太搞笑了。太搞笑了。随着节目的进行，她还会给我们爆出更多精彩的猛料。
We now have a great scene with Angela and Oscar. They're over in accounting, but they're acting like an old married couple. Like she's saying, did you pack the snacks? And he's like, no, I told you to pack the snacks. And she says, well, whenever I pack the bag, you tell me I pack it wrong. And Kevin's like, guys, hey guys, guys. Yeah, Kevin's like, guys,
We now have a great scene with Angela and Oscar. They're over in accounting, but they're acting like an old married couple. Like she's saying, did you pack the snacks? And he's like, no, I told you to pack the snacks. And she says, well, whenever I pack the bag, you tell me I pack it wrong. And Kevin's like, guys, hey guys, guys. Yeah, Kevin's like, guys,|||接下来是安吉拉和奥斯卡的精彩对手戏。他们在会计部，但表现得像一对老夫老妻。比如她说：“你收拾零食了吗？”而他说：“没有，我让你收拾零食的。”她说：“哼，每次我收拾包，你都说我装得不对。”然后凯文说：“伙计们，嘿，伙计们，伙计们。”对，凯文说：“伙计们，
I want you to see this funny video on my computer. Look at my computer. Where someone says bold instead of cold. It's not that funny, Kevin. But then Kevin has an amazing talking head. It might be my favorite talking head of the entire series. Okay, well, you are not alone. Katie F from London, UK said, I have been waiting four years and ten years
I want you to see this funny video on my computer. Look at my computer. Where someone says bold instead of cold. It's not that funny, Kevin. But then Kevin has an amazing talking head. It might be my favorite talking head of the entire series. Okay, well, you are not alone. Katie F from London, UK said, I have been waiting four years and ten years|||我想让你们看我电脑上的这个搞笑视频。看我的电脑。里面有人把“cold”（冷）说成了“bold”（大胆）。没那么好笑，凯文。但接着凯文有一段绝妙的独白。这可能是我整部剧中最喜欢的独白了。好吧，你不是一个人。来自英国伦敦的凯蒂·F说：我等了四年又十年
because this aired 10 years ago. Got it. To tell you that Kevin's line in this episode is my favorite line of the entire series. I'm with you and I think we should hear it. Let's hear it. Philip, Philip, Philip. It's all about Philip.
(because this aired 10 years ago. Got it.) To tell you that Kevin's line in this episode is my favorite line of the entire series. I's with you and I think we should hear it. Let's hear it. Philip, Philip, Philip. It's all about Philip.|||（因为这集是10年前播出的。明白了。）就是为了告诉你，凯文在本集里的台词是我整部剧中最喜欢的台词。我赞同你的看法，我觉得我们应该听听看。听听看吧。菲利普，菲利普，菲利普。到处都是菲利普。
I hate Philip. Here's what I want you to know about that talking head. It was not the one in the script. It was a candy bag alt. Oh my gosh. Yes. And I can share with you two other versions. Ready? Yes. So here's how it was scripted.
I hate Philip. Here's what I want you to know about that talking head. It was not the one in the script. It was a candy bag alt. Oh my gosh. Yes. And I can share with you two other versions. Ready? Yes. So here's how it was scripted.|||我讨厌菲利普。关于那段独白，我想让你们知道的是：它并不是剧本里原本写的。它是一个备选笑话。天哪。是的。我可以跟你们分享另外两个版本。准备好了吗？好。剧本原本是这样写的：
Philip, Philip, Philip. It's all about Philip. I hope Philip runs away. Oh, and this was another candy bag alt. And it really made me laugh. It's all about Philip. I hope Philip runs away. Oh. And this was another candy bag alt, and it really made me laugh. Kevin says, on the one hand, Philip is a cute baby. On the other hand, I hate his stupid face
Philip, Philip, Philip. It's all about Philip. I hope Philip runs away. Oh, and this was another candy bag alt. And it really made me laugh. It's all about Philip. I hope Philip runs away. Oh. And this was another candy bag alt, and it really made me laugh. Kevin says, on the one hand, Philip is a cute baby. On the other hand, I hate his stupid face|||菲利普，菲利普，菲利普。到处都是菲利普。我希望菲利普离家出走。哦，这是另一个备选笑话。真的把我逗笑了。到处都是菲利普。我希望菲利普离家出走。哦。这也是另一个备选笑话，真的把我逗笑了。凯文说：一方面，菲利普是个可爱的婴儿。另一方面，我讨厌他那张蠢脸，
and wish he'd go to baby hell. Kind of like that one. Anyway, Katie and London, I'm with you. Such a fantastic talking head. Well, this really points to that dynamic that you talked about originally, Angela, which is that you always felt like you were this dysfunctional family over in a county
and wish he'd go to baby hell. Kind of like that one. Anyway, Katie and London, I'm with you. Such a fantastic talking head. Well, this really points to that dynamic that you talked about originally, Angela, which is that you always felt like you were this dysfunctional family over in a county|||并希望他下婴儿地狱。挺喜欢这个版本的。总之，伦敦的凯蒂，我和你感同身受。太棒的一段独白了。好吧，这真的印证了你最初谈到的那种关系，安吉拉，也就是你一直觉得你们在会计部就像是一个功能失调的家庭，
where you and Oscar were the parents and Kevin was your kid. And now here you have your next kid and he's very jealous. We have a jealous toddler. You do. All right, Jim is gonna walk into Dwight's office and Dwight's like, not now, private time. I do have a background catch.
where you and Oscar were the parents and Kevin was your kid. And now here you have your next kid and he's very jealous. We have a jealous toddler. You do. All right, Jim is gonna walk into Dwight's office and Dwight's like, not now, private time. I do have a background catch.|||你和奥斯卡是父母，凯文是你们的孩子。现在你们迎来了下一个孩子，而他非常嫉妒。我们迎来了一个吃醋的幼儿。确实如此。好吧，吉姆走进德怀特的办公室，德怀特说：现在不行，私人时间。我确实捕捉到一个背景穿帮。
What is it? Eight minutes, 55 seconds. When the camera widens up, the mobile, the hierarchy mobile is moving. So I think this was like a second take or a retake cause it hadn't like gotten still. I think you're right. I think that's true. That's my background catch. I liked it. Well, Jim is going to say we've overlooked something. What?
What is it? Eight minutes, 55 seconds. When the camera widens up, the mobile, the hierarchy mobile is moving. So I think this was like a second take or a retake cause it hadn't like gotten still. I think you're right. I think that's true. That's my background catch. I liked it. Well, Jim is going to say we've overlooked something. What?|||是什么？8分55秒时。当镜头拉远时，那个挂饰，那个层级移动挂饰还在动。所以我猜这是拍第二条或者重拍，因为还没静止下来。我觉得你说得对。我也觉得是这样。这就是我捕捉到的背景穿帮。我挺喜欢的。好吧，吉姆要说我们漏掉了什么。什么？
Some PFN. That's right. Potential future nonsense. They're looking at the mobile. He says, look at it. We do not have an assistant to the assistant to the regional manager. We sure don't. Dave Rogers told me. Rain improvised a line here and it's so good. Which part? Is it about the hierarchy mobile? When Jim points to it, Rain came up with the line, I'd have to get some more wire and string, but it's doable. I liked that line. Very, very good. Good job, Rain. Very good job, Rain. Good job, Rain.
Some PFN. That's right. Potential future nonsense. They're looking at the mobile. He says, look at it. We do not have an assistant to the assistant to the regional manager. We sure don't. Dave Rogers told me. Rain improvised a line here and it's so good. Which part? Is it about the hierarchy mobile? When Jim points to it, Rain came up with the line, I'd have to get some more wire and string, but it's doable. I liked that line. Very, very good. Good job, Rain. Very good job, Rain. Good job, Rain.|||一些“PFN”。没错。潜在的未来胡闹（Potential Future Nonsense）。他们正看着那个挂饰。他说：看呐。我们没有“区域经理助理的助理”。确实没有。戴夫·罗杰斯告诉我的。雷恩在这里即兴发挥了一句台词，太棒了。哪一部分？是关于层级移动挂饰的吗？当吉姆指着它时，雷恩想出了一句台词：“我得弄点更多的电线和绳子，不过这行得通。”我喜欢这句台词。非常、非常棒。干得好，雷恩。干得好，雷恩。干得好，雷恩。
He's gonna MacGyver it. Meanwhile, Andy and Casey Dean are hitting it off. And host Mark McGrath is gonna come out and address the crowd. How charismatic was he? Oh my gosh. I so believed him as this character. We asked Dave how we got him for the show.
He's gonna MacGyver it. Meanwhile, Andy and Casey Dean are hitting it off. And host Mark McGrath is gonna come out and address the crowd. How charismatic was he? Oh my gosh. I so believed him as this character. We asked Dave how we got him for the show.|||他要用“马盖飞”式的方法拼凑起来。与此同时，安迪和凯西·迪恩相谈甚欢。主持人马克·麦格拉思走了出来，向人群发表讲话。他多有个人魅力啊？天哪。我太相信他就是这个角色了。我们问戴夫是怎么请到他来演这部剧的。
Dave said that they were hoping to get an Entertainment Tonight, like, extra type host. And Mark McGrath was perfect because he had been doing extra and also he is a musician himself. Yeah. You know, lead singer of the band Sugar Ray, everybody. That's right. Yeah. Dave said that when Mark McGrath said yes
Dave said that they were hoping to get an Entertainment Tonight, like, extra type host. And Mark McGrath was perfect because he had been doing extra and also he is a musician himself. Yeah. You know, lead singer of the band Sugar Ray, everybody. That's right. Yeah. Dave said that when Mark McGrath said yes|||戴夫说，他们希望能找一个像《今夜娱乐》那种风格的外景主持人。马克·麦格拉思简直完美，因为他以前主持过外景，而且他本人就是个音乐人。对。大家知道的，摇滚乐队“糖果合唱团”（Sugar Ray）的主唱。没错。对。戴夫说，当马克·麦格拉思答应
to doing this part, he was so excited. Dave loves Sugar Ray. He said he has all their albums and he even had Mark's duet with Shania Twain, you know that song Party for Two, on a CD mix in his car. On the day we filmed it? No, no, just in general. Oh, because that would have been kind of wild if he pulled up and was listening to him at the same time.
to doing this part, he was so excited. Dave loves Sugar Ray. He said he has all their albums and he even had Mark's duet with Shania Twain, you know that song Party for Two, on a CD mix in his car. On the day we filmed it? No, no, just in general. Oh, because that would have been kind of wild if he pulled up and was listening to him at the same time.|||出演这个角色时，他兴奋极了。戴夫超爱“糖果合唱团”。他说他有他们所有的专辑，甚至还在他车里的混音CD里收录了马克和仙妮亚·唐恩的合唱曲目——你知道那首歌《Party for Two》的。在我们拍摄的那天吗？不，不，就是平时。哦，因为如果他开车过来时正好在听这首歌，那就太疯狂了。
Dave also shared with us that he was once at a rooftop movie premiere and saw Mark talking to some people, but he was too nervous to go up and tell him he was a huge fan. So now you fast forward to the morning that they're shooting these scenes together and Dave, I guess, went into hair and makeup. And when he entered the trailer,
Dave also shared with us that he was once at a rooftop movie premiere and saw Mark talking to some people, but he was too nervous to go up and tell him he was a huge fan. So now you fast forward to the morning that they're shooting these scenes together and Dave, I guess, went into hair and makeup. And when he entered the trailer,|||戴夫还跟我们分享说，他有一次在一个屋顶电影首映礼上看到马克在跟一些人聊天，但他太紧张了，没敢上前告诉马克自己是他的超级粉丝。所以时间快进到他们一起拍摄这些场景的早晨，戴夫去化妆间做造型。当他走进拖车时，
he said, Where's the rock star? And he said Mark couldn't have been friendlier. He was really excited to play the part and he nailed the performance on the first take. Yeah. And Dave said, As a side note, Mark graciously invited him and a friend to be guests at his upcoming Sugar Ray show at the Greek Theater and Dave had a blast. Yes, Steve Burgess also talked about how amazing Mark was to work with. He confirmed that he nailed all his stuff on the first take and Jessica St. Claire also enjoyed working with Mark. Here's what she had to say. I also remember being very attracted to Mark McGrath and understanding why he had the career he did.
he said, Where's the rock star? And he said Mark couldn't have been friendlier. He was really excited to play the part and he nailed the performance on the first take. Yeah. And Dave said, As a side note, Mark graciously invited him and a friend to be guests at his upcoming Sugar Ray show at the Greek Theater and Dave had a blast. Yes, Steve Burgess also talked about how amazing Mark was to work with. He confirmed that he nailed all his stuff on the first take and Jessica St. Claire also enjoyed working with Mark. Here's what she had to say. I also remember being very attracted to Mark McGrath and understanding why he had the career he did.|||他说：“摇滚巨星在哪儿呢？”他说马克简直不能再友好了。他非常兴奋能演这个角色，而且第一条就完美完成了表演。对。戴夫还顺便提到，马克非常慷慨地邀请他和一位朋友去希腊剧院观看他即将举行的“糖果合唱团”演唱会，戴夫玩得超开心。是的，史蒂夫·伯吉斯也谈到和马克合作有多么令人惊叹。他证实马克所有戏份都是一遍过，杰西卡·圣克莱尔也很享受和马克合作。她是这么说的：我还记得自己当时被马克·麦格拉思深深吸引，也理解了他为什么能拥有如今的职业生涯。
He's got Riz for days, but I did spend a majority of my time on set trying to catch the eye of Mr. McGrath. And sadly, we never had our moment where our eyes locked over craft service. But I'm not ruling it out, you know, but yeah, I think that's a woman of a certain age, like myself, can really get her motor running about Mark McGrath.
He's got Riz for days, but I did spend a majority of my time on set trying to catch the eye of Mr. McGrath. And sadly, we never had our moment where our eyes locked over craft service. But I'm not ruling it out, you know, but yeah, I think that's a woman of a certain age, like myself, can really get her motor running about Mark McGrath.|||他魅力四射、魅力无极限，不过我在片场的大部分时间其实都在试图吸引麦格拉思先生的注意。遗憾的是，我们在剧组餐点区附近从未有过四目相对的浪漫时刻。但我并不排除这种可能，你知道的，不过是的，我觉得像我这个年纪的成熟女性，真的会对马克·麦格拉思怦然心动。
So that was a real highlight. Well, I'm a woman of a certain age, and I think all of us remember Mark McGrath. Yeah, he's got the Riz. He's got the Riz. For days. I went on his IMDB page, Ange, and I found this very funny trivia tidbit that I have to share.
So that was a real highlight. Well, I'm a woman of a certain age, and I think all of us remember Mark McGrath. Yeah, he's got the Riz. He's got the Riz. For days. I went on his IMDB page, Ange, and I found this very funny trivia tidbit that I have to share.|||所以那真的是一个高光时刻。好吧，我也是个成熟女性，我想我们所有人对马克·麦格拉思都有印象。对，他太有魅力了。他太有魅力了。魅力无边。我上了他的IMDB页面，安吉，我发现了一个非常搞笑的冷知识，我必须分享一下。
Okay. It said that he is so often mistaken for Ethan Hawke that he sometimes just signs autographs as Ethan Hawke. And apparently the same thing happens to Ethan Hawke who signs autographs as Mark McGrath. That's so funny. Isn't that funny? Yeah. Well, I have one thing to point out from the script for this scene. You know when Mark mentions the mole and then he's like, oh, I wasn't supposed to say that. And then Andy's like, what mole? What are you talking about? I
Okay. It said that he is so often mistaken for Ethan Hawke that he sometimes just signs autographs as Ethan Hawke. And apparently the same thing happens to Ethan Hawke who signs autographs as Mark McGrath. That's so funny. Isn't that funny? Yeah. Well, I have one thing to point out from the script for this scene. You know when Mark mentions the mole and then he's like, oh, I wasn't supposed to say that. And then Andy's like, what mole? What are you talking about? I|||好。上面说他经常被误认为是伊桑·霍克，以至于他有时干脆直接以伊桑·霍克的名字签名。显然伊桑·霍克也遭遇了同样的事情，会以马克·麦格拉思的名字签名。太搞笑了。是不是很搞笑？对。好吧，关于这场戏的剧本，我有一点要指出。你知道当马克提到那个痣，然后他说：“哦，我不该说这个的。”接着安迪说：“什么痣？你在说什么？我
already forgot about it. And Mark goes, good man right there. I'll see you guys inside. Good luck. All right. And then Andy's like, yeah, pour some sugar ray on me. And Casey Dean goes, wow, on a roll much? You totally made a connection there. And Andy's like, yeah, it felt good. It felt funny. I love this interaction so much. I went to the script to see if they had improvised any of it. I think they might have a little bit, but there was a scripted line I thought was really funny where Andy would have said, I should be resting my folks, but I can't stop riffing. Oh my gosh, the writers must have loved writing for Andy. Rest in my vokes. So good. So good. Now we're in the kitchen. Jim is pouring Pam a cup of coffee. He's very giddy. He's
already forgot about it. And Mark goes, good man right there. I'll see you guys inside. Good luck. All right. And then Andy's like, yeah, pour some sugar ray on me. And Casey Dean goes, wow, on a roll much? You totally made a connection there. And Andy's like, yeah, it felt good. It felt funny. I love this interaction so much. I went to the script to see if they had improvised any of it. I think they might have a little bit, but there was a scripted line I thought was really funny where Andy would have said, I should be resting my folks, but I can't stop riffing. Oh my gosh, the writers must have loved writing for Andy. Rest in my vokes. So good. So good. Now we're in the kitchen. Jim is pouring Pam a cup of coffee. He's very giddy. He's|||已经忘光了。”马克说：“好样的。待会儿里面见。祝你好运。”好吧。然后安迪说：“耶，把糖果合唱团（Sugar Ray）的糖倒在我身上吧。”凯西·迪恩说：“哇，状态大好啊？你们俩刚才挺对脾气的。”安迪说：“对，感觉不错。挺有意思的。”我太喜欢这段互动了。我去查了剧本，看看他们有没有即兴发挥。我觉得他们可能稍微发挥了一点，但剧本里有一句台词我觉得特别搞笑，安迪本该说：“我本该让我的嗓子（vokes）休息的，但我就是停不下来即兴发挥。”天哪，编剧一定特别喜欢为安迪写台词。“让我的嗓子休息”（Rest in my vokes）。太棒了。太棒了。现在我们来到厨房。吉姆正在给帕姆倒一杯咖啡。他兴高采烈的。他
having fun with this prank. We find out that he says by 2 p.m. Dwight is going to choose himself as the AARM, thereby making himself Jim's assistant. Now Darryl pulls up to the warehouse. He borrowed one of the warehouse trucks to deliver all his furniture to Philly. He has officially moved to Philly. He's all in. We find out that Darryl hates goodbyes, so he pulled an Irish exit and left before anyone noticed. No hard feelings, no feelings at all. Yes, please. And do not tell anyone he's there.
having fun with this prank. We find out that he says by 2 p.m. Dwight is going to choose himself as the AARM, thereby making himself Jim's assistant. Now Darryl pulls up to the warehouse. He borrowed one of the warehouse trucks to deliver all his furniture to Philly. He has officially moved to Philly. He's all in. We find out that Darryl hates goodbyes, so he pulled an Irish exit and left before anyone noticed. No hard feelings, no feelings at all. Yes, please. And do not tell anyone he's there.|||正乐此不疲地享受着这个恶作剧。我们发现他说，到下午2点时，德怀特会选择自己担任“区域经理助理的助理”（AARM），从而让自己成为吉姆的助理。此时达雷尔把车开到了仓库。他借了一辆仓库货车，把所有的家具都运到了费城。他正式搬到费城了。他全心投入了。我们发现达雷尔讨厌道别，所以他“爱尔兰式逃跑”（不告而别），在所有人注意到之前就离开了。没有芥蒂，一点感觉也没有。求之不得。而且千万别告诉任何人他在那儿。
He doesn't want anyone to know. All right, now we're going to see what these challenges are to find the AARM. Challenge number one is know your superior. And I guess the way you know your superior is by predicting what they're thinking? Yes. Jim is like, what am I thinking? What song is in my head? No one can guess what Jim is thinking except Jim and Dwight say seahorse at the same time.
He doesn't want anyone to know. All right, now we're going to see what these challenges are to find the AARM. Challenge number one is know your superior. And I guess the way you know your superior is by predicting what they're thinking? Yes. Jim is like, what am I thinking? What song is in my head? No one can guess what Jim is thinking except Jim and Dwight say seahorse at the same time.|||他不想让任何人知道。好了，现在我们要看看为了选出AARM有哪些挑战。挑战一：了解你的上级。我猜了解上级的方式就是预测他们在想什么？是的。吉姆说：我在想什么？我脑子里是什么歌？没人能猜到吉姆在想什么，除了吉姆和德怀特同时说出了“海马”。
That's right. What are the odds of that? I mean, they're pretty good based on how this went down. Don't you think so? Yeah. Because what Jim did is just start to say a word as Dwight already said it. Let's do it, Jenna.
That's right. What are the odds of that? I mean, they're pretty good based on how this went down. Don't you think so? Yeah. Because what Jim did is just start to say a word as Dwight already said it. Let's do it, Jenna.|||没错。这几率有多大？我的意思是，从当时的情况来看，几率还挺高的。你不觉得吗？对。因为吉姆的做法是，当德怀特已经说出一个词时，他才开始说。我们来试试，珍娜。
Ready? What am I thinking of right now? What? What? You're doing it. Stop it. Can I say something? What?
Ready? What am I thinking of right now? What? What? You're doing it. Stop it. Can I say something? What?|||准备好了吗？我刚才在想什么？什么？什么？你在学我。停下。我能说句话吗？什么？
This is an acting exercise. Kristen Wiig and Fred Armisen on Saturday Night Live have a bit where they... They are the best at it. But they're singing. I know. As well. And then they're having to create a story, like new information. It is so good.
This is an acting exercise. Kristen Wiig and Fred Armisen on Saturday Night Live have a bit where they... They are the best at it. But they're singing. I know. As well. And then they're having to create a story, like new information. It is so good.|||这是个表演练习。克里斯汀·韦格和弗莱德·阿米森在《周六夜现场》里有一个小品，他们……他们在这方面最厉害了。但他们在唱歌。我知道。也是。然后他们得编个故事，比如加入新的信息。太精彩了。
It's the best. It is. It's the best at this bit. It's so great. The whole bit is they have to sing a song on Weekend Update and it comes across like they haven't prepared and they're making it up on the spot. And they are. And visually they're having to watch each other to see what words they're saying.
It's the best. It is. It's the best at this bit. It's so great. The whole bit is they have to sing a song on Weekend Update and it comes across like they haven't prepared and they're making it up on the spot. And they are. And visually they're having to watch each other to see what words they're saying.|||太棒了。确实。这个小品简直绝了。太棒了。整个小品的设定是，他们必须在“周末更新”环节唱一首歌，表现得好像他们根本没排练过、全凭现场现编一样。而他们也确实是现编的。在视觉上，他们必须看着彼此，以防漏掉对方唱的词。
We should put one of them in stories. It's so funny. We have to. All right. Challenge number two. We're in the conference room and we're going to talk about protocols. What do you do if there is a conference room meeting of very important people and a phone message comes in? Dwight hands this phone message to Clark who immediately reads it out loud and insults one of the people at the table.
We should put one of them in stories. It's so funny. We have to. All right. Challenge number two. We're in the conference room and we're going to talk about protocols. What do you do if there is a conference room meeting of very important people and a phone message comes in? Dwight hands this phone message to Clark who immediately reads it out loud and insults one of the people at the table.|||我们应该把其中一个片段发到快拍里。太搞笑了。我们必须这么做。好。挑战二。我们在会议室里，要讨论规章制度。如果有一场由非常重要的人物参加的会议，此时来了一个电话留言，你该怎么做？德怀特把这张电话留言递给克拉克，克拉克立刻大声读了出来，并侮辱了桌上的一个人。
Dwight is like, no, you don't read it. Clark has failed. Clark Green. Yes. Not gonna get a corndog. Does not get a corndog. Once again, Dwight is the only person who knows how to solve this problem properly. That's right. It's uncanny. I know. Uncanny. Mm-hmm. Jim has a lot of clipboard acting in this episode. A lot of pen clicking. A lot of pen clicking, writing stuff on a clipboard. Check mark making. Check marking. He's a clipboard guy. He really is. Well, back in line for America's Next Acapella Sensation,
Dwight is like, no, you don't read it. Clark has failed. Clark Green. Yes. Not gonna get a corndog. Does not get a corndog. Once again, Dwight is the only person who knows how to solve this problem properly. That's right. It's uncanny. I know. Uncanny. Mm-hmm. Jim has a lot of clipboard acting in this episode. A lot of pen clicking. A lot of pen clicking, writing stuff on a clipboard. Check mark making. Check marking. He's a clipboard guy. He really is. Well, back in line for America's Next Acapella Sensation,|||德怀特说：不，你不能读出来。克拉克失败了。克拉克·格林。对。吃不到玉米热狗了。吃不到玉米热狗了。又一次，德怀特成了唯一一个知道如何正确解决这个问题的人。没错。太神了。我知道。太神了。嗯。吉姆这一集里有很多拿剪贴板的表演。有很多按笔的声音。有很多按笔、在剪贴板上写字。打勾。做标记。他就是个“剪贴板男孩”。他真的是。好了，镜头回到“美国下一个阿卡贝拉轰动节目”的排队现场，
Andy and Casey are really bonding over the fact that they're getting annoyed with other people that they think are gonna be pulling at the heartstrings of the judges. There's a army veteran, there's like a single mom, and they're sort of chatting about it Well when we were filming this episode, I guess a real-life drag race started to happen like on the street Oh, wow. Yeah, and everyone's like reacting to it. It's in the bloopers. I thought it was so wild I want you to hear it
安迪和凯西真的很有共鸣，因为他们对其他人感到很恼火，觉得那些人会去触动评委的心弦。有个退伍军人，还有个单亲妈妈之类的，他们就在那儿聊天。好吧，我们拍这一集的时候，我猜街上好像发生了一场现实生活中的飙车。哦，哇。对，然后每个人都在做出反应。这在NG花絮里。我觉得太疯狂了，我想让你们听听
Over by the porta potties. They were interviewing a homeless single mother with three kids. What? Who cares? Is that your ride? What is going on? What is happening? I think we can keep that one. What is happening? Is that a bank robbery?
就在移动厕所旁边。他们在采访一个带着三个孩子的无家可归的单亲妈妈。什么？谁在乎？那是你的车吗？怎么回事？发生什么了？我觉得我们可以保留那个。发生什么了？那是抢劫银行吗？
What just happened? It was crazy. Oh my goodness. Did you hear how loud it was? Yes. Well, I asked Jessica about this and here's what she had to say. Now, apparently there was a drag race happening
刚刚发生什么了？太疯狂了。哦天哪。你听到声音有多大吗？听到了。嗯，我问过杰西卡这件事，她是这么说的。现在，显然当时发生了一场飙车
during the scene when we were standing online. I don't have a memory of that, but I do remember that everyone on the line, all the background actors were so lovely and just a fun hang, you know? And that isn't always the case, but everyone was so excited to be there.
就在我们排队的那个场景拍摄期间。我没有那段记忆，但我确实记得排队的每个人，所有的群演都非常可爱，在一起玩得很开心，你知道吗？情况并非总是如此，但每个人都很高兴能来到这里。
I think there was, you know, everyone was sort of a fan of the office and everyone was really bringing like a backstory to their characters. So that was really fun. Some of my favorite things to shoot are like situations like this, where you're in this like big line or big group of people for multiple scenes
我觉得大家，你知道的，每个人都算是《办公室》的粉丝，每个人真的都为自己的角色带入了一段背景故事。所以那真的很有趣。我最喜欢拍摄的一些场景就像这样，你置身于这样一个大队伍或一大群人中，要拍好几个场景
because you really do kind of end up making up your own stories in the background and they become some of the most fun shoot days. Yeah, there's a guy with a cowboy hat in the background. Yes. I kept watching him. He clearly had a story for himself. I should point out that our guest star
因为你真的会最终在背景里编造出你自己的故事，而这些会成为最有趣的拍摄日之一。对，背景里有一个戴牛仔帽的家伙。对。我一直在看着他。他显然为自己编了一段故事。我应该指出我们的客串明星
who played the veteran was Nico Evers Swindle. He has been on Veep, American Horror Story, and Grim. He also played Prince William in the movie William and Kate. Wow. And everyone, Jessica is so amazing and funny. We're gonna have more audio clips to share with you next week.
饰演退伍军人的演员是尼科·埃弗斯-斯温德尔（Nico Evers Swindle）。他演过《副总统》、《美国恐怖故事》和《格林》。他还演过电影《威廉与凯特》中的威廉王子。哇。而且大家，杰西卡是如此出色又有趣。我们下周还有更多的音频剪辑要分享给你们。
And definitely check out her podcast with June Diane Raphael called The Deep Dive. And you also have to listen to her audio book with Casey Wilson. It is called The Art Dive. And you also have to listen to her audio book with Casey Wilson. It is called The Art of Small Talk. It's on Audible. It is so funny. The two of them are so hilarious.
一定要去听听她和琼·黛安·拉斐尔（June Diane Raphael）的播客《深潜》（The Deep Dive）。你还得听她和凯西·威尔逊（Casey Wilson）合作的有声书。书名叫《闲聊的艺术》。你还得听她和凯西·威尔逊合作的有声书。书名叫《闲聊的艺术》。它在Audible上有售。太搞笑了。他俩简直太爆笑了。
They're gonna give you all the advice you need to go to any event with some great small talk. I feel like my trick of walking up to people laughing could be in this book. Okay. That's just a preview of some of their advice. I think that would qualify. They would like it.
他们会把你需要的所有建议都交给你，让你带着伟大的闲聊技巧去参加任何活动。我觉得我那种走过去哈哈大笑的绝招也可以写进这本书里。好吧。那只是他们的一些建议的预告。我觉得这绝对够格。他们会喜欢的。
Well, Andy is going to decide if the judges want a feel-good moment, he's going to give him a feel-good moment. He says, save my place in line, and he takes off. Yeah. What's Andy got up his sleeve? Oh, something good. Yeah. Once Andy got up his sleeve. Oh something good. Oh we're over at Caffeine Corner now and I'll be damned if they don't have donuts. Caffeine Corner! So many! They never had donuts! I remember being super excited to go over there and I did sneak one. They let
好吧，安迪打算如果评委们想要一个温馨的时刻，他就给他们一个温馨的时刻。他说，帮我占着队里的位子，然后他就跑开了。对。安迪葫芦里卖的是什么药？哦，绝对是好东西。对。安迪葫芦里到底卖的什么药。哦，好东西。哦，我们现在来到咖啡角了，如果他们没有甜甜圈的话，我就把名字倒着写。咖啡角！有这么多！他们从来没有过甜甜圈！我记得当时超级高兴能去那里，我还偷拿了一个。他们让我
me have one. Well that's where we were doing all of our interviews for the look-back. Yeah. Mm-hmm. Darrell's gonna buy some to give some of the warehouse guys. He felt bad I guess because he didn't say goodbye to him. And Pam asked him how's it going at Athlead? Darrell couldn't be happier. He's so stoked. He's gonna like meet all of his sports heroes. He'll go to 32 different cities. He can't believe that Jim is happier at Dunder Mifflin. Yeah, he says he's not having any second thoughts about leaving athlete and Pam is like nope. I mean he seems happy. He seems happy. He's just gonna try to recreate
拿了一个。好吧，那就是我们做所有回溯采访的地方。觉。嗯-hmm。达瑞尔要买一些送给仓库的伙计们。他大概觉得挺内疚，因为他没有跟他们道别。潘问他在Athlead过得怎么样。达瑞尔高兴极了。他兴奋坏了。他能见到他所有的体育偶像。他要去32个不同的城市。他简直不敢相信吉姆在邓德米夫林反而更开心。对，他说他离开athlete后没有丝毫后悔，潘则是一副“才没有”的表情。我的意思是，他看起来很高兴。他看起来很高兴。他只是打算试着重现
Office Olympics. Pretty much. Maybe a call for help. We're in the warehouse and there is a coffee obstacle course set up. Yeah you have two cups of hot coffee your boss needs his coffee. Here's the thing it's super piping hot. You got to step over three different sizes of like stacks of paper and then you go through this chair obstacle spinny thing. Yeah the chairs are upside down the wheels are spinning. This obstacle course was originally scripted to be outside, but Dave Rogers moved it into the warehouse. He said he moved it for two reasons. One, because he thought
办公室奥运会。差不多吧。也许是在呼救。我们在仓库里，那里设置了一个咖啡障碍赛。嗯，你有两杯热咖啡，你老板需要他的咖啡。问题是，这超级烫。你得跨过三种不同高度的像纸堆一样的障碍，然后你要穿过这个椅子障碍旋转装置。对，椅子是倒过来的，轮子在转。这个障碍赛原本剧本里是安排在户外的，但戴夫·罗杰斯（Dave Rogers）把它搬到了仓库里。他说他搬进来有两个原因。第一，因为他觉得
it would be easier for Aaron to spot Daryl at the end if they were in the warehouse than if they were outside in the alley. But also he said whenever we did a lot of scenes outside we would all get hot and grouchy. And so he was like, let's move it inside folks. I saved myself. Exactly. Some grouchy folks. Phyllis is up first on the obstacle course and she's moving too slowly. Dwight can't take it. He like grabs the coffee from her, starts running through it, he's spilling coffee on himself,
如果他们在仓库里，比起在户外的巷子里，艾伦会更容易在终点看到达瑞尔。但他也说，每当我们在户外拍很多戏时，大家都会又热又暴躁。所以他就说，伙计们，我们把它搬到室内吧。我自救了。没错。有些脾气暴躁的人。菲莉丝第一个上障碍赛，但她移动太慢了。德怀特忍不了了。他一把从她手里夺过咖啡，开始往前冲，咖啡洒在了自己身上，
it's like burning him, but you know what? He's going to get that coffee to his boss, which is himself. I would like to award myself a Razzie for my performance in this scene? Oh my God, I could barely watch it. Could I be telegraphing or showing or indicating anymore? Everyone, if you wanna be an actor, don't do what I'm doing in this scene. Stop it. I am serious, like everything about me, it's like, does anyone have eyes on me?
就像在烧他一样，但你知道吗？他要把那咖啡送到他老板手上，也就是他自己。我想为我在这个场景中的表演颁发一个金酸莓奖？哦天哪，我简直没眼看。我还能表现得、展示得或暗示得更明显一点吗？大家伙儿，如果你们想当演员，千万别学我在这场戏里的表现。住手。我是说真的，我整个人都在散发着一种“有没有人在看我”的感觉。
Like, how is Jim not noticing that I've turned into a complete sad sack and I'm just standing there like a big wet blanket? I mean, how about some subtlety, Jenna? When Jenna says a Razzie Award, she's talking about a thing called the Golden Raspberry Awards. It's a parody and it's an award show honoring the worst in cinematic failures.
就像，吉姆怎么会没注意到我已经变成了一个彻头彻尾的扫兴鬼，而且我就像一块湿漉漉的大毛毯一样站在那儿？我的意思是，稍微含蓄一点行吗，珍娜？当珍娜说金酸莓奖时，她指的是一个叫做金酸莓奖（Golden Raspberry Awards）的东西。这是一个恶搞奖项，也是一个旨在表彰电影界最烂失败作品的颁奖典礼。
Yes. They don't even cover television, but I think they should make an exception for me. It's a parody and it's an award show honoring the worst in cinematic failures. Yes. They don't even cover television, but I think they should make an exception for me. Stop it! I disagree. Ugh. Well, anyway, as if you couldn't tell, Pam is now very preoccupied with this idea that Daryl has planted in her head that maybe Jim is not actually as happy as he seems.
是的。他们甚至不涉及电视节目，但我认为他们应该为我破例。这是一个恶搞奖项，也是一个旨在表彰电影界最烂失败作品的颁奖典礼。是的。他们甚至不涉及电视节目，但我认为他们应该为我破例。住手！我不同意。呃。好吧，总之，就像你一眼能看出的那样，潘现在满脑子都在想着达瑞尔植入她脑海里的那个想法：也许吉姆其实并没有表面看起来那么开心。
Yeah, Jim is going to present Dwight with a crown that he's made out of tinfoil and cardboard. Everyone applauds, but Pam, in fact, she runs outside. Very dramatically. Runs away. Overly dramatic, Pam. Dave said that Rain improvised a line at the end of this scene. Originally, it was going to end with Pam running out, but Rain improvised this line and I loved it so much. He says, from now on, anyone who needs to speak to me
对，吉姆要送给德怀特一顶他用锡纸和纸板做成的王冠。大家都鼓掌了，但潘却跑出去了。非常戏剧化地。跑开了。戏精潘。戴夫说雷恩在这一场戏的结尾即兴发挥了一句台词。原本结局是潘跑出去就结束了，但雷恩即兴加了这句台词，我太喜欢了。他说，从今以后，任何需要跟我对话的人
has got to go through me first. That was so good. That was really funny. Rain knew his character so well. So well. Well, Jim is going to catch up to Pam outside. They're in that little alley by the warehouse and she she's worried Jim's like, Are you okay? And she says today was fun. But what about a year from now? What about five years from now? You know, she's worried that she's not enough for him and that he's going to resent her. I need to pick up my mug. Okay, here it comes pockets mug. All right, this is when Pam lost me. Uh oh. Okay. I'm gonna eat my granola bar, go. For most of the season, Jim has been on my sh** list, but all of this is
都必须先通过我这一关。太棒了。真的太搞笑了。雷恩对他的角色了解得太透彻了。太透彻了。好吧，吉姆要在外面追上潘。他们就在仓库旁边的那个小巷子里，她，她很担心，吉姆就说：“你还好吗？”她说今天挺开心的。但一年后呢？五年后呢？你知道的，她担心自己对他是远远不够的，他最终会怨恨她。我得去拿我的马克杯。好吧，口袋马克杯来咯。好吧，这就是潘让我粉转黑的时候。哦不。好吧。我要吃我的格兰诺拉麦片棒了，开始。整个大半个季度里，吉姆都在我的黑名单上，但所有这一切
very crazy making to me on Pam's part. Hold up, are you calling bullsh** on Pam? Are you playing a bullsh** card? I don't know if it's a full bullsh** card because this is in character for them. This is just where their relationship is making me a little crazy. But herein lies the problem. In this scene, Jim says, This was my decision to come back, okay? I'm not going to resent you. This was my decision.
对潘的做法来说，简直让我抓狂。等等，你是在对潘的所作所为鸣不平吗？你是在打“胡扯”牌吗？我不知道这算不算一张完全的“胡扯”牌，因为这很符合他们的人设。这只是他们俩的关系让我觉得有点抓狂的地方。但问题就在这里。在这个场景中，吉姆说：“这是我决定回来的，好吧？我不会怨恨你的。这是我的决定。”
That's everything you need to you. This was my decision. That's everything you need to know. This is their problem. He decided to start the business and now he's decided to give up the business. Why are they not making decisions together and I am losing my mind? He bought a house. Yes. I remember hearing this amazing advice very early on about decision-making in marriage, and this is what I want to say to Jim and Pam. When you're at odds over something, but you reach a compromise, or you do eventually make a decision, that decision is not complete
这就是你需要知道的一切。这是我的决定。这就是你需要知道的一切。这就是他们的问题所在。他决定开始这项事业，现在他又决定放弃这项事业。为什么他们不一起做决定，而我要被逼疯了。他买了一栋房子。对。我记得很早以前听过关于婚姻中决策的一个绝妙建议，而这也是我想对吉姆和潘说的话。当你对某事有分歧，但你做出了妥协，或者你最终做出了决定，这个决定并不完整
until you both agree to take responsibility for the decision. So later on, if something goes wrong, you can't be like, see, I knew it, or like, well, that was you. You're the one who wanted it. Yeah, no, I told you so. None of that. Whatever the consequence is, we both made it. And if Jim and Pam had made the decision together
直到你们双方都同意对这个决定承担责任。所以后来如果出了什么差错，你不能说“看吧，我早就知道了”，或者“好吧，那是你的事。是你自己想要这个的”。对，没错，我早就告诉你了。这些统统不行。无论结果如何，这是我们共同做出的。如果吉姆和潘当初共同做出了
to start this business, and they took mutual responsibility for how that decision played out, we'd be in a very different situation right now. If Pam was unhappy with that decision, too bad, because you made that decision together. You're going to have to tough it out, Pam. That was a mutual decision. These are the consequences of your mutual decision.
开始这项生意的决定，并且他们为这个决定的发展结果承担共同责任，我们现在就会处于一个完全不同的境地了。如果潘对那个决定不满意，那也只能怪她，因为那是你们共同做出的决定。潘，你得咬牙坚持下去。那是共同的决定。这就是你们共同决定的后果。
But all that happens is Jim makes decisions. But Pam is like letting this happen, too. You know what I mean? Like, she just sort of like... Well, she's got to be more vocal. Yes. And he's got to stop making decisions without her. Jim is like letting this happen too, you know what I mean? Like she just sort of like... Well, she's got to be more vocal. Yes. And he's got to stop making decisions without her.
但实际情况却是吉姆一个人做决定。不过潘也算是听之任之了。你知道我的意思吗？就是她差不多就像是……好吧，她应该更多地表达自己的意见。是的。而他必须停止在没有她的情况下去做决定。吉姆也算是听之任之了，你知道我的意思吗？就是她差不多就像是……好吧，她应该更多地表达自己的意见。是的。而他必须停止在没有她的情况下去做决定。
Yes. Thank you. Mug down. Thank you for hearing me. Well, Jim is going to have a talking head now. He's going to say, not enough. And then he looks at the documentary crew and he said, look, I need to ask a favor from you guys.
对。谢谢。放下马克杯。谢谢你听我倾诉。好吧，吉姆现在要有一个独白了。他说，不够。然后他看着纪录片摄制组说，听着，我需要你们帮个忙。
I know it's probably against the rules. And then we hear Dave Rogers voice say, okay, you got it, man. Very quick to say yes, I have to say. I know. I thought maybe they'd be like, um, let me think about it. Let me talk to some people. Or maybe just don't have them respond at all. I didn't think we needed the response. I didn't either. It sort of like threw me for a second. I love that Dave's voice got in the episode because I love him. But I also was like, well, that was quick. Well, you know, we've heard the documentarian's voice one other time and it was Dave at that time as well. Yes. You know, Dave said originally he just recorded his voice as like a temporary voice track. Yeah. And that the intention was that Greg Daniels would provide the voice of the documentarian. But Greg was like, no, I want it to be you. Meanwhile, Kevin is really acting
我知道这可能违反规定。然后我们听到戴夫·罗杰斯的声音说，好吧，没问题，伙计。我得说，答应得真快。我知道。我还以为他们会说，嗯，让我想想。让我跟其他人商量一下。或者干脆不让他们回应。我觉得我们其实不需要那个回应。我也不觉得需要。这让我稍微愣了一下。我很喜欢戴夫的声音能出现在这一集里，因为我很爱他。但我也觉得，好吧，这也太快了吧。不过，你知道的，我们听过纪录片制作人的声音还有另外一次，那次也是戴夫。对。你知道的，戴夫说最初他录下自己的声音只是作为临时配音轨。对。而且原本的意图是让格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）来为纪录片制作人配音。但格雷格却说，不，我想要你来。与此同时，凯文真的因为
out over his lack of attention. He's throwing a tantrum. He says to Angela and Oscar, you know what? Tell Philip that a stupid little baby wish came true. But Angela and Oscar don't have time to deal with this. They're trying to get Philip down for a nap. They've created kind of a bed out of the bottom drawer of the file can, but they've pulled it out. They've put a bunch of blankets in. They've made a little, like a little bassinet. They have a little mattress thing on the bottom and some of his stuffed animals.
缺乏关注而开始作妖。他在发脾气。他对安吉拉和奥斯卡说，你知道吗？告诉菲利普，一个愚蠢的小婴儿愿望成真了。但安吉拉和奥斯卡根本没空应付这个。他们正试图哄菲利普睡午觉。他们用文件柜最底层的抽屉临时做了一张床，把它拉开了。他们在里面塞了一堆毯子。他们做了一个类似于小摇篮的东西。底部有一个小垫子和一些他的毛绒玩具。
But Philip is too excited to nap. Yeah, Angela said he's very excited to be surrounded by all this paper and he even ate some of the paper, which Dwight overhears and is like, well, that's the best tasting paper. Hmm. Hmm. Meanwhile, in the break room, Phyllis, Erin and Meredith are confronting Darryl about the fact that he left without saying goodbye. Now Stanley's there too, but he's just kind of eating his lunch in the background. He's weighing in, but he's not as passionate about this problem. Oscar shows up there too. Oh, you're right. Yeah, clearly they
但菲利普太兴奋了，根本睡不着。对，安吉拉说他被周围这么多的纸包围着感到非常兴奋，他甚至还吃了一些纸，德怀特无意中听到后就说，嗯，那可是最好吃的纸。嗯。嗯。与此同时在休息室里，菲莉丝、艾伦和梅雷迪思正在质问达瑞尔，质问他为什么不告而别就走了。现在斯坦利也在那儿，但他只是坐在背景里吃着午餐。他也在发表意见，但对这个问题的热情没有那么高。奥斯卡也出现在那里。哦，你说的对。对，很显然他们
love Daryl and they wanted more time with him and they're really bummed he did the Irish exit. Daryl says, wow, they're definitely in a weird mood. I picked the wrong day to return a truck. I have a mug catch. Oh, let's hear it. Both Meredith and Creed are using their mugs from customer survey. Oh, that was season five. Yes. I just love the dedication to this mug thing. Me too. Well in Dwight's office him and Esther are now having a picnic and just standing right outside the window of his office Angela and Pam were having a whole conversation and Angela's holding Philip but she's not really paying attention to what Philip is looking at or doing. She's just chatting away with Pam. Are Pam and Angela friends? I don't know.
很爱达瑞尔，并且想和他多待一会儿，对于他来了个“爱尔兰式不告而别”，他们感到非常沮丧。达瑞尔说，哇，他们的情绪真的很诡异。我选错了还卡车日子。我有马克杯收集癖。哦，听听这个。梅雷迪思和克里德用的都是他们从客户调查里拿到的马克杯。哦，那是第五季的。是的。我就是喜欢这种对马克杯执着的精神。我也是。好吧，在德怀特的办公室里，他和埃丝特现在正在野餐，而就在他办公室窗户外面的正前方，安吉拉和潘正在聊天，安吉拉抱着菲利普，但她并没有真正关注菲利普在看什么或做什么。她只是在和潘聊天。潘和安吉拉是朋友吗？我不知道。
I mean, I do think children bring them together in a way. In a way. I'll say that. Well, while Angela's holding Philip and chatting away, Philip is only got eyes for one thing. The Galactica. He points at it, he's smiling. Dwight clocks all of this. He can't even focus on what Esther's saying. Yeah, and you know, this picnic in his office, this was gonna be a marriage proposal.
我的意思是，我觉得孩子们确实以某种方式把她们拉近了。某种程度上。我只能这么说。好吧，正当安吉拉抱着菲利普聊天的时候，菲利普的眼里却只有一样东西。银河战舰（Galactica）。他指着它，微笑着。德怀特把这一切尽收眼底。他甚至无法专心听埃丝特在说什么。对，你知道的，他办公室里的这次野餐，本来是要进行求婚的。
Yeah, he puts the ring back in his pocket. He does. Dwight has a talking head where he says the way Philip looks at the Galactica is the same way he looks at it. Hmm. And they even eat the same kind of paper. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Well we had to ask Dave Rogers about the scene because a while back he shared with us his love of Battlestar Galactica and how it influenced the character of Dwight. Here's what he told us. For this episode, it was scripted that Dwight paints
对，他把戒指放回了口袋。他确实这么做了。德怀特有一段独白，他说菲利普看着银河战舰的眼神，就像他自己看它时的眼神一模一样。嗯。而且他们连吃的纸都是同一种。嗯-hmm。嗯-hmm。好吧，我们不得不问问戴夫·罗杰斯关于这个场景的事，因为不久前他跟我们分享了他对《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》（Battlestar Galactica）的热爱，以及这部剧是如何影响德怀特这个角色的。他是这么跟我们说的。对于这一集，剧本原本写的是德怀特画了
and hangs a model of the Battlestar Galactica in his office. And just to go back in history for a second, when Dave met Greg Daniels after watching the pilot, he pitched that Dwight should like Battlestar Galactica and have a Viper, one of the individual fighterships on his desk. Yes, Dave talked about this in his interview with us, that originally Dwight was going to love Star Trek,
并在他的办公室里挂了一个太空堡垒卡拉狄加的模型。为了回顾一下历史，当戴夫在看完试播集后遇到格雷格·丹尼尔斯时，他提议说德怀特应该喜欢《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》，并在桌上摆一个“毒蛇号”（Viper，其中一艘单人战斗飞船）的模型。是的，戴夫在接受我们采访时谈到过这一点，原本德怀特是打算喜欢《星际迷航》的
which he does love Star Trek, but Dave pitched that it would be cooler if he liked this kind of niche sci-fi thing. And that is why Dwight came to love Battlestar Galactica. Yes, Dave said Greg even bought him a model of the original Galactica Cylon base ship for one of his birthdays. And when they were prepping this episode, Phil Shea asked if Dwight would have an original
虽然他也确实喜欢《星际迷航》，但戴夫提议说，如果他喜欢这种偏门冷门的科幻题材会更酷。这就是为什么德怀特后来会迷上《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》。是的，戴夫说格雷格甚至在他的一次生日时给他买了一个原版卡拉狄加塞昂（Cylon）母舰的模型。当他们为这一集做准备时，菲尔·谢伊（Phil Shea）问德怀特应该用原版
series Galactica or the new series Galactica. He loves both series, but he wanted the original Galactica. And when the show wrapped filming, Phil Shea said that he could keep it and gave it to him. And Rain signed it and wrote, Dave Galactica loves you and he has it to this day displayed in his office. And we saw it when we did our interview with him. We could see it hanging in the background. Well I was wondering if we had to get special permission to use the ship but Steve Burgess said, legal said use it
系列的卡拉狄加还是新系列的卡拉狄加。他两个系列都很喜欢，但他想要原版的卡拉狄加。当剧集拍摄杀青时，菲尔·谢伊说他可以留着它，并把它送给了他。雷恩在上面签名并写道：“戴夫，卡拉狄加爱你”，而且他至今仍把它摆在自己的办公室里。当我们对进行采访时，我们亲眼看到了。我们能看到它挂在背景里。好吧，我当时在想我们是不是必须获得特殊许可才能使用这艘飞船，但史蒂夫·伯格斯（Steve Burgess）说，法务部说用吧
just use it. Oh. He said that we were not using it in any way that it was not intended. Like it was a model that you paint and hang and that's what we did with it. So it was okay. And also we weren't saying anything bad about it. And also it's a universal show. Okay.
直接用。哦。他说我们使用的任何方式都没有违背它的初衷。就像它本来就是一个供你上色和悬挂的模型，而这正是我们对它所做的。所以没问题。而且我们也没有说它的任何坏话。再说了，这也是一部环球影业的剧。好吧。
Well, Dwight shows Esther out the door. He gets a bean bag that says now on it and throws it at the back of Jim. The summoning bag. Yes, it's a summoning bag. And he tells Jim he's going to need him to perform a test on a baby. Jim says, I've got a busy day, writes something on his clipboard, tears it off. More clipboard acting. And says, you know what?
好吧，德怀特送埃丝特出门。他拿了一个上面写着“现在”字样的懒人豆袋椅，朝吉姆的后背砸了过去。召唤袋。对，这是一个召唤袋。他告诉吉姆，他需要他去对一个婴儿进行测试。吉姆说：“我今天有很多工作要忙”，在剪贴板上写了点东西，撕下来。更多的剪贴板演技。然后说：“你知道吗？”
He's going to pass this off to his number two unless he can't handle it. And Dwight assures him he can. Dun, dun, dun. To be continued. Yes. Well, there you have it, folks. That is AARM.
他要把这个任务交给他的二把手，除非他搞不定。而德怀特向他保证他绝对能搞定。咚，咚，咚。未完待续。是的。好吧，各位，你们听到了。这就是《AARM》。
Part one. Next week is AARM part two. Big thank you to Dave Rogers. To Steve Burgess, Jessica St. Clair. Don't forget to check out Jessica's audiobook, The Art of Small Talk, available on Audible. And I want to remind everybody that Kendra Adachi's book, The Plan, is out now.
第一部分。下周是《AARM》第二部分。非常感谢戴夫·罗杰斯。感谢史蒂夫·伯格斯、杰西卡·圣克莱尔。别忘了去听杰西卡的有声书《闲聊的艺术》，在Audible上即可收听。我想提醒大家，肯德拉·阿达奇（Kendra Adachi）的书《计划》（The Plan）现已上市。
We talked about it last week. That's right. And you guys, we hope you have a great day. We can't wait to see you next week. We have some really fun stuff coming up. See you then. See you then. See you then.
我们上周聊过这个。没错。各位，我们希望你们今天过得愉快。我们迫不及待想在下周见到你们。我们有一些非常有趣的内容要带给大家。到时候见。到时候见。到时候见。
See you then. See you then. See you then. See you then. See you then. See you then. See you then. See you then.
到时候见。到时候见。到时候见。到时候见。到时候见。到时候见。到时候见。到时候见。
See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis.
到时候见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是奥德赛（Audyssey）旗下节目，由珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）和安吉拉·金斯利（Angela Kinsey）制作。我们的执行制作人是卡西·杰金斯（Cassie Jerkins）。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer）。我们的副制作人是艾斯利·布巴科（Ainsley Bubbaco）。奥德赛的执行制作人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼（Jenna Weiss-Berman）和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）。
Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴西尔（Chris Basil）混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《橡皮树》。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。